Ich bin ein Kumpel von Kumpel.
Ich bin ein Kumpel von Kumpel. Ich bin ein Kumpel von Kumpel.
Kraftwerk Numbers, wie immer, im letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Komischer Knick in meinem Mikrofon, ich musste kurz mal. Und wie immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat im Blue Moon hier auf Fritz, Chaosradio, heute Teil 132. Zu Gast sind Konstanze, Frank und Erdgeiss. Wunderbar, guten Abend.
Guten Abend.
Und ich bin natürlich ebenfalls zu Gast. Wir sind alle nur Gäste auf dieser Welt, aber das soll nicht Thema der heutigen Sendung sein. Thema der heutigen Sendung ist ein ganz aktuelles. Ihr kommt nämlich quasi direkt aus dem Zug und wart in Karlsruhe beim Bundesverfassungsgericht. Die ja heute über den so viel geschmähten, viel diskutierten und ungeliebten Bundestrojaner diskutiert haben.
Korrekt. Wir sind also gerade aus dem Zug gehüpft.
Gibt es denn einen Kaffeeautomaten beim Bundesverfassungsgericht? Oder wie läuft das da?
Also ich muss zugeben, dass wir keinen gesehen haben, aber sie haben immerhin eine Security wie am Flughafen da.
Eigens viel netter.
Also so mit irgendwie alles auspacken und gehen sie bitte, ziehen sie die Schuhe aus.
Genau, nur dass es keine 5, 15 Euro-Kräfte sind, sondern Beamte. Und die sind sehr freundlich und haben sehr viel Zeit.
Vielleicht könnt ihr mal kurz zusammenfassen, was ihr heute erlebt habt beim Bundesverfassungsgericht.
Na, warum es ging, war ja ein Landesgesetz von Nordrhein-Westfalen, die hatten ja die sogenannte Online-Durchsuchung vorgesehen für den Verfassungsschutz. Dabei geht es darum, einen Trojaner auf Computer von Verdächtigen einzuschleusen, also ein Programm, mit dem man die Daten auf dem Computer aus der Ferne auslesen und auch verändern kann und darauf die Peripheriegeräte des Computers zugreifen kann.
Die so viel bezeichnete Online-Durchsuchung.
Genau, da geht es um einen sehr breiten Komplex. Da gab es im Oktober eine mündliche Verhandlung, die schon sehr großartig war, wo sich die Landesvertreter und die Vertreter der Bundesregierung ziemlich barmiert haben. Auch Juristen, die dagegen waren, meinten, so eine Watscha haben sie noch nie erlebt für tatsächlich den Staat und heute war nun da die Urteilsverkündung, wo tatsächlich ein sehr komplexes Urteil dabei rausgekommen ist. Das Landesgesetz für Nordrhein-Westfalen wurde gekippt. Es ist tatsächlich so, dass dieses Gesetz verfassungswidrig war. Und zusätzlich haben die Richter uns ein neues Grundrecht beschert, was irgendwie nur so alle 25 Jahre hervorkommt. Insofern ist es tatsächlich ein historischer Tag in der Geschichte.
Und dieses Grundrecht bezeichnet sich aus Sicht der Verfassungsrichter wie folgt?
Der juristische Name dafür ist, dass dieses Grundrecht die Vertraulichkeit und Integrität von informationstechnischen Systemen gewährleistet. Das ist so der Begriff. Eigentlich heißt es, dass wir auch in digitalen Bereichen Teamsphäre haben. Dass es auch für virtuelle Damen, die wir verrechnen haben oder die in Netzen liegen, einfach ein Grundrecht gibt. Dass es da auch einen Kernbereich gibt, der eben zu schützen ist. Und sie haben extrem hohe Hürden, den Ermittlern auferlegt. Und nur unter diesen dürfen sie halt auf solche Daten zugreifen.
Das heißt, wenn ich mich jetzt dafür interessiere, was du auf deiner Festplatte hast, kannst du dich auf dieses neue Grundrecht berufen und kannst sagen, ist nicht.
Nee, du bist ja kein staatlicher Ermittler.
Neugierige, eine neugierige, große Nase. Also um das kurz zusammenzufassen, dieses Gesetz, was es in NRW gab, was heute gekippt wurde, ihr habt ja gerade gesagt, die haben da von den Experten, haben die Politiker eine ziemliche Watsche bekommen, wurde jetzt, aber es ist ja trotzdem durch. Vom Verfassungsgericht haben sie eine Watsche bekommen.
Also es war so, dass die irgendwann fragte der Vorsitzender Richter, den Vertreter des Staates des Landes NRW, ob man denn vom selben Gesetz reden würde. Weil der hat halt einfach nur gefaselt. Also es war tatsächlich nur hochnotpeinliche Veranstaltung für die Bundesseite, doch für die Landseite da. Und nicht nur die Experten haben einigermaßen einhellig gesagt, das geht so nicht. Auch die Richter haben sich schon damals mit den Fragen de facto angeschlossen. Und so kam dann halt heute dieses Urteil daraus.
Neben diesem neuen Grundrecht, was Konstanz ja gerade angesprochen hat, ist es trotzdem heute durch den Nachrichtengang, vielleicht habt ihr es ja auch gesehen oder gehört, dass sich die Politiker weiterhin auf die Schultern klopfen und sagen, dieses Gesetz ist weiterhin in Deutschland da. Also die Online-Durchsuchung, wie auch immer sie jetzt rein fachterminiert im juristischen Jargon heißt. Nur es gibt eben einige Eingrenzungen und Regelungen. Also es müssen besondere Genehmigungen vorliegen von Richtern, damit man die Festplatten von Leuten durchsuchen kann und so. Und Herr Schäuble will das trotzdem mit aller Vehemenz weiter raustragen. Also das Gesetz ist weiterhin da, es ist verändert worden.
Es gab bisher kein Gesetz, es gab dieses Landesgesetz in Nordrhein-Westfalen, was nun tatsächlich gekippt ist, das ist tatsächlich verfassungswidrig, darf so nicht angewendet werden. Aber worum es sehr implizit ging dabei, war die Diskussion über das neue Gesetz fürs Bundeskriminalamt, was ebenfalls diese Befugnisse bekommen sollte. Und die große Diskussion ging ja darum, dürfen sie das überhaupt, wenn ja unter welchen Voraussetzungen? Und die Voraussetzungen, die die Richter da heute gesetzt haben, sind sehr, sehr eng. Also sie haben gesagt, nicht nur der bloße Verdacht reicht nicht aus, sondern es müssen halt konkrete Anhaltspunkte für schwerste Straftaten, also de facto halt schwerer Terrorismus vorliegen, bevor überhaupt auch nur angefangen werden kann, diesen Prozess eine Genehmigung dafür zu kriegen, anzufangen.
Also der Traum, den Herr Schäuble hatte, dass er jedem Bürger irgendwie eine E-Mail schickt, denn der, dieser Bundestrojaner drin ist, der ist damit vom Tisch.
Der ist damit definitiv ausgeträumt. Also die Hürden, die da gesetzt wurden, sind ähnlich hoch wie beim großen Lauschangriff. Das heißt also, da muss halt ein Richter eine ausführliche Begründung schreiben, wieso tatsächlich dieser Angriff jetzt stattzufinden hat und was davon zu erwarten ist und ob es überhaupt verhältnismäßig ist. Da können wir nachher noch ein bisschen im Detail drauf eingehen, wie genau diese Schranken aussehen. Aber de facto ist es so, dass damit die Anzahl von Fällen, in denen es überhaupt noch versucht werden kann, dramatisch eingeschränkt wurde.
Das heißt, wir sind auch aus Sicht der Datenschützer und auch aus Sicht vom Chaos Computer Club ein, kann man sagen, ein Schritt weg vom Überwachungsstaat und haben ein bisschen mehr Persönlichkeit und Intimsphäre schützen können. Kann man dazu sagen?
Das kann man deutlich so sagen.
Also ein Sieg.
Es ist auf jeden Fall ein Sieg. Da kann sich der Bundesinnenminister hinstellen, wie er möchte erst mal und sagen, es ist ja nicht verboten worden. Aber de facto das Gesetz ist nichtig. Und wir haben dieses neue, tatsächliche Grundrecht, was an der Menschenwürde hängt, also unsere Verfassungsgrundsätze, Artikel 1 und 2, und was man erst mal nicht wegdiskutieren kann. Und da bezieht sich tatsächlich diese große Urteilung auf andere Sachen, außer nur die Online-Durchsuchung. Etwa muss man daran denken, dass ja auch, wenn Rechner beschlagnahmt werden, etwa nach einer Hausdurchsuchung oder in anderer Weise beschlagnahmt werden, dass auch dann jetzt mal andere Grundsätze für diese digitalen Daten einfach eingehalten werden müssen. Also es wird noch andere Folgen haben.
Ja, also aus unserer Sicht ist ja damit die Verfassung im Internet-Zeitalter angekommen. Und das war auch die explizite Absicht der Richter. Also da können wir nachher noch mal ein bisschen in Details gehen. Das Urteil ist halt wie gesagt sehr lang und komplex. Und sie haben halt sehr weitgehend ausgeführt und auch sehr weitsichtig agiert. Nicht nur gesagt, okay, die Festplatte im Computer, sondern in allen digitalen Geräten. Und es ist egal, wo sich dieser Computer befindet, ob innerhalb der Wohnung oder außerhalb. Und es bezieht sich halt auch auf entfernt gespeicherte Daten, also sprich Daten, wenn man einen Server irgendwo hat, seine Backups dahintut und das ist ein eigener Server oder ein eigener Teil von einem Server. Und man kann halt eigentlich berechtigt erwarten, dass da niemand anders reinguckt. Dann genießen die Daten da genau den Silmschutz, als wenn sie halt auf der eigenen Festplatte sind.
Gilt es nur für Festplatten im Rechner oder jetzt beispielsweise auch für einen Speicherchip oder eine Digitalkamera?
Sie haben das sehr erweitert, denn in dem Verfassungsschutzgesetz war ja sowieso nie von Computern die Rede, sondern immer nur von informationstechnischen Systemen, was ja ein deutlich breiterer Begriff ist. Und so haben sie in der Urteilsbegründung auch ganz deutlich gemacht, dass etwa Mobiltelefone davon ebenfalls betroffen sind, aber auch Computernetze, also dass eben vernetzte Geräte dabei sind. Insofern ist es deutlich erweitert worden.
Das heißt, wenn die Prämisse steht, dass also wirklich Anhaltspunkte für schwerste Straftaten gelten, dass dann also auf solche Daten zugegriffen werden kann oder dass dann diese Online-Diskussion durchgeführt werden kann, da hat das dann auch Auswirkungen auf den normalen User wie dich, mich und viele von euch am Radio, die Musik auf der Festplatte haben und sonstige Geschichten, wo dann natürlich bei so einem Urteil auch Leute kommen und sagen, wir würden gerne mal gucken, was der Rest der Welt auf seinen Festplatten hat. Da kann also nicht irgendjemand kommen und klingeln mir eine Marke unter die Nase halten und sagen, ich nehme meinen Rechner mit.
Das wäre früher oder später wahrscheinlich sowieso gekommen, weil alle Gesetze, die sie erlassen haben, um gegen die bösen Terroristen, gegen Nazis oder Kinderschinder vorzugehen, wurden früher oder später dann immer weiter aufgeweicht und zum Ende einfach nur gegen Fallschere angewandt. Also haben wir auch einen guten Schritt getan für die Jungs und Mädels zu Hause, die einfach nur ihre Lieblingsmusik aus dem Netz holen, dass dort nicht plötzlich der BND oder das BKA vor der Tür steht und die Rechner mitnehmen möchte.
Also ein Tag voller Freude, voller Applaus, dieser 27. Februar 2009.
Kann man so sagen, ja.
Ein Sieg auf voller Linie. Es gibt ein neues Grundrecht und zwar das Grundrecht auf digitale Intimsphäre. Das haben die Karlsruher Verfassungsrichter heute beschlossen und so festgestellt. Der Chaos Computer Club hat so schön formuliert, damit ist auch die Verfassung im Internet-Zeitalter angekommen. Und die Internet-Ausdrucker haben sich jetzt mal in Ruhe auf einer Kaffeepause zurückgezogen. Das jetzt zu den großen Details. Ihr habt gerade erzählt, wie läuft ihr da in Karlsruhe ab? Sicherheitskontrollen wie am Flughafen, alles hoch, streng. Und ansonsten, da springen ja Politiker rum, und ein Haufen Presseleute und Kamera und so. Wie läuft denn da so ab, so eine Tragung vom Bundesverfassungsgericht?
Naja, es ist eigentlich ein sehr spannendes Prozedere für jemanden, der noch nie da war. Und wir haben ja auch zur Anhörung das erste Mal dieses Bundesverfassungsgerichtsgebäude betreten. Es ist natürlich alles sehr formal geregelt. Da sind halt eine Menge Gerichtsdiener unterwegs, die dafür sorgen, dass sich die Presse an die Regeln hält, aber auch die Besucher. Und jetzt beim Bundestrojaner war natürlich sowohl eine Anhörung wie heute bei der Urteilsverkündung total voll. Also da sind dann sehr viele Besucher und auch viele Presse schon draußen natürlich. Und die Verfahrensbeteiligten, hier insbesondere die Kläger, aber auch die sozusagen Gegenseite, also die Vertreter einmal des Bundestages waren da, aber auch natürlich der nordrhein-westfälischen Landesregierung. Die werden dann natürlich vorab befragt. Und sofern dann eben die Urteilsverkündung vorbei ist, dann werden sie noch mal befragt. Das ist halt schon ein ziemlicher Pressehype. Nun war natürlich so, das war nicht sehr überraschend. Wir wussten natürlich im Prinzip, dass dieses Verfassungsschutzgesetz keinen Bestand haben würde, aber niemand wusste wirklich, wie dieses neue Grundrecht, ob es eins geben würde und wie dies aussehen würde. Insofern war natürlich auch spannend.
Ist das, wenn die Richter das verkünden, gibt es da Murmeln oder Graune im Saal? Da muss man sich da zurückhalten, weil der Ungerichtsdiener sagt Pssst, pssst.
Heute war es sehr formal und sehr gesetzt. Bei der Anhörung im Oktober war es so, dass man eigentlich fast auf den Zehnenapplaus gewartet hat. Da gab es durchaus auch Gelächter im ganzen Saal, wenn sich da der Vertreter der Landesregierung...
Wir wollen mal seinen Namen nennen. Es war Professor Heckmann, der sich da so blamiert hat.
Genau, wenn der sich da mal wieder kräftig in den Sumpf gefahren hat.
Was hat er denn gemacht zum Beispiel?
Ach na, der hat ja einfach versucht mit hanebüchenster Argumentation das Gesetz unzuinterpretieren, so auf offener Bühne. Also er wollte den Richtern einreden, das stünde doch alles da gar nicht so, wie das halt offensichtlich da stand und ähnliche Dinge. Also es war halt, er hat sich da wirklich nach allen Maßstäben wirklich blamiert und alle haben es gemerkt so. Und auch die Mimik der Verfassungsrichterin, der dann sprachhaft wirklich großartig, also der Vorsitzende Richter hat Papier, hat ja ein sehr bewegtes Minenspiel, allein dem zuzugucken, wenn er dann die Augenbraue hochzieht, wenn der sich dann mal wieder irgendwie vergreift, der Heckmann, dann, das war halt schon die Reise wert. Heute war es relativ formal, es fängt halt so an, also die Sitzung fängt halt Punkt 10 an, so ab 9.15 Uhr ist halt Einlass, dann gibt es halt eine lange Schlange. Man steht dann an der Sicherheitskontrolle an, ist halt wie am Flughafen, also mit Metalldetektor und Röntgen und so. Dann versammeln sich da alle so unten in der Lobby und schwatzen noch ein bisschen, ein paar Interviews werden geführt, dann kann man sich dann noch hochsetzen irgendwann. Und dann wird Punkt 10, kommt dann da so eine Saaldienerin raus, stellt sich da sehr formell hin und sagt, das Bundesverfassungsgericht und dann geht die Tür auf und dann kommen die dann halt da raus in ihren roten Robben.
Vorher stehen natürlich alle Leute noch auf.
Genau, also wenn die dann das ansagt, dann müssen alle Leute aufstehen. Dann kommen die dann da raus, gewanderten in ihren roten Robben und setzen sich halt sehr würdig dann da hin und setzen dann ihre roten Mützen ab. Und dann beginnt halt das eigentliche Prozedere. Also der Vorsitzende Richter öffnet dann die Verhandlungen und so weiter.
Und wenn da über so einen hochkomplizierten, merkwürdig verfassten, halb unverständlichen Text beschlossen wird, wie lange dauert denn das?
Also für die Urteilsfindung lässt sich das Verfassungsgericht ja traditionell so viel Zeit wie es braucht. Also es gibt halt Prozesse, die jahrelang da rumliegen, wenn die sich halt nicht so richtig einig werden können oder nicht so richtig eine Meinung bilden können. Hier war es halt relativ zügig. Also es war jetzt zwischen der Verhandlung und der Urteilsverkündung war eigentlich mal ein halbes Jahr. Die Verhandlung damals im Oktober hat viele Stunden gedauert.
Also 6 Stunden mindestens, aber Unterhaltung auf hohem Niveau hat echt Spaß gemacht.
Also es war halt so intellektuelle Unterhaltung für, also selbst für Leute, die jetzt nicht irgendwie jeden Paragraphen da mit verstehen.
Nee, war auch für Nerds, durchaus. Also weil es ja um technische Aspekte ging. Wir hatten da Spaß, weil die Rechner, trotzdem man davon ausgehen kann, dass sie eigentlich nicht zur Internet- und Computer-Generation gehören, die richtige technische Fragen gestellt haben. Sie haben halt genau auf die Schwachstellen gepiekt und so richtig in den Wunden gebohrt, wo es sich die Gegenseite ganz schön winden musste.
Ja, die Politiker des selben Alters waren da wohl deutlich weniger informiert. Es hat auch Spaß gemacht, dazu zu gucken, dass es einfach keine Frage des Alters ist, sondern einfach eine Frage der Agilität und der Lust, sich damit zu beschäftigen.
Also man muss schon sagen, die Damen und Herren, da wir Bundesverfassungsgericht sind, so mit, würde ich mal sagen, die Leute in diesem Staat, die ihr Geld wirklich verdienen.
Also noch größer kann das Kompliment, glaube ich, nicht sein über das Bundesverfassungsgericht. Karlsruhe hat heute beschlossen, dass es ein neues Grundrecht gibt auf Intimsphäre. Und der viel geschmähte Bundestrojaner hat so viele Grenzen und so viele Schranken vor die Füße gelegt bekommen, dass das schon einen ziemlichen Aufwand braucht. Zum Beispiel den direkten Verdacht auf schwerste Straftaten, dass das Ding überhaupt in Kraft gesetzt wird. Dass der große feuchte Traum vom Bundesinnenminister und von vielen anderen jetzt erstmal eine ganze Weile etwas auf kleinerer Flamme kocht. Ein großer Tag für die Demokratie, ein großer Tag für die Menschenrechte, so kann man es durchaus pathetisch formulieren. Und damit sind wir im Chaosradio 132 hier auf Fritz schon drin. Frank, Konstanze und Erdgeist sind bei uns. Und wir würden gerne mit euch ein bisschen über diese neuen Grundrechte, die wir jetzt haben, schwatzen. Wie findet ihr denn das neue Grundrecht auf digitale Intimsphäre? Was haltet ihr davon? Findet ihr das super? Ist es überflüssig? Habt ihr vielleicht diese ganze Verlauf über den Bundestrojaner mitbekommen? Habt ihr eine Meinung dazu, dass das jetzt so viele Schranken bekommen hat? Dann rufen wir uns an, 0331 70 97 110. Ihr könnt natürlich auch berichten, wenn ihr Erfahrungen gemacht habt mit Beschlagnahme von Computern oder auf eurer Festplatte, quasi euer zweites Gehirn habt, wo ihr sagt, da kommt mir keiner ran. Und das ist auch gut so, dass da keiner rankommt. Es wird eine lustige Sendung am heutigen 27. Februar. Wie die anwesenden Damen und Herren schon richtig sagten, ein wichtiger und großer Tag. Und deswegen spielen wir jetzt die Ärzte Deine Schuld. Das sollte man sich auf der Zunge zergehen lassen. Erdgeist rockt mit, als ob er in einer Schuldisco zu viel Cola getrunken hat. Aber genau das Lied heute zum Tag. Das Lied zum Tag. Chaosradio auf Ritz, Teil 132. Konstanze, Frank und Erdgeist sind zu Gast. Wir reden über den Sieg beim Bundesverfassungsgericht, über den Bundestrojaner, so könnte man das Volksthema nicht formulieren und wollen mit euch über diese Entscheidung reden und über das neue Grundrecht auf digitale Inzimsphäre. Und am Telefon ist Christian aus Brandenburg. Name, Christian. Das ist schön. Hallo, Christian. Ohne Pfeifen. Du hast ein neues Grundrecht. Und zwar das Grundrecht auf digitale Inzimsphäre. Wie findest du das?
Na gut, eigentlich.
Was bedeutet das für dein Leben? Hast du irgendwas auf deinem Rechner, wo du sagst, das ist quasi mein zweites Gehirn und ohne meinen Computer bin ich kein richtiger Mensch?
So direkt ja vielleicht nicht, aber so Sachen, die ich vielleicht kein anderer sehen sollte.
Die du jetzt aber im Radio allen Leuten erzählen willst.
Ja, warum nicht?
Was ist denn auf deinem Computer drauf?
So schöne Fotos von meiner Freundin oder so zum Beispiel.
Die hat deine Freundin weiß aber, dass du die Fotos gemacht hast? Ahja, okay, alles klar. Die gehen natürlich eigentlich wirklich niemandem was an.
Das ist doch ein gutes Beispiel dafür, was man nicht ausgeschnüffelt haben will.
Gerade nicht von den älteren Ermittlungsbeamten, die da vielleicht noch ganz andere Interessen haben.
In dem Fall sind glaube ich nicht mal die Ermittlungsbeamten jetzt wichtig, sondern vielleicht auch die Eltern oder Freunde von Christian, die sagen, warte mal hier, ich mach dir mal den Rechner klar. Oh, was ist das denn? Du kannst dir sagen, ich hab hier Grundrechts, heute in Karlsruhe entschieden worden. Was ist das, deine Freundin im Hintergrund? Alles klar, dann grüß mal deinen Zimmergenossen ganz herzlich und sieh zu, dass in Zukunft auch niemand an die Fotos seiner Freundin drankommt, außer den Leuten, die sie was angehen. 0331-7797-110. Wir haben aber Leute Spaß. Am Telefon ist Stan aus Greifswald. Hallo, Stan. Grüß dich, du hast eine Rückfrage zur Urteilsbegründung.
Genau, und zwar hab ich so ein bisschen heute alles mitverfolgt und hab dann ein bisschen die ganzen Weblogs verlesen. Alle? Markus Beckedahl und Sprebelig und so. Und ich hätte jetzt eine Nachfrage dazu, wie jetzt konkret die gesetzlichen Hürden sozusagen ausgerichtet sind. Es gab so ein paar Stimmen, die gesagt haben, ja super, aber sie dürfen ja doch.
Irgendwie kamen sie heute alle aus dem Bundesverfassungsgericht raus und irgendwie hatten alle ein Lächeln im Gesicht. Alle haben gesagt, für uns ist es auch okay.
Also ich finde, ich teile echt die Einschätzung von Konstanze und euch. Aber wie sieht es jetzt konkret aus? Also es gab so ein paar kritische Stimmen, die nachher meinten, ja wenn die das wollen, dann finden die irgendeinen Richter, der sagt, ja mach das. Also das ist ja keine absolute Schranke drin, weil sie das sicherlich noch hätten nicht ausdrücken können. Aber wie sind die Schranken konkret ausgerichtet?
Also die Urteilsbegründung, also die Mündliche sagt zu dem Thema, dass ein Richter eine ausführliche Begründung erstellen muss. Er kann es nicht durchwinken, wie bei einer Telefonüberwachung, wo die rechtfertige Genehmigung de facto abstempelt von einem Formular ist. Sondern muss halt tatsächlich im Einzelfall prüfen, ob dieser Eingriff angemessen ist. Also sprich, ob tatsächlich die Schwere des Verdachts da ist, ob der Verdacht hinreichend konkret ist. Also da haben sie sehr drauf rumgeritten, die Richter, als sie sagten, okay, so eine Allgemeine, der könnte ein Terrorist sein. Verdächtigung reicht bei weitem überhaupt nicht aus. Sondern es muss halt ein konkreter Verdacht auf eine zeitnahe Bedrohung vorliegen.
Und diese Bedrohung ist auch noch konkret spezifiziert. Also es muss eine existentielle Notlage vorliegen für Leib und Leben von anderen Menschen oder den Staat bedrohen. Also es kann auch nicht irgendeine Straftat sein. Das ist tatsächlich vergleichbar etwa mit den Schranken, die beim großen Lauschangriff, also beim Schnüffeln in den Schlafzimmern, also man jetzt akustisch oder optisch den Wohnraum bewachen will. Das ist etwa vergleichbar, das heißt, die Schranken sind so hoch, dass wir zumindest in absehbarer Zukunft nicht ganz viele Fälle von diesen Bundestrojanern sehen werden.
Aber die Formulierung konkreter Verdacht auf konkrete Bedrohung könnte man jetzt auch wieder auslegen. Gibt es da irgendwie einen Katalog, wo man sagt...
Nein, der Katalog besteht aus genau zwei Zeilen. Da steht tatsächlich drinnen Gefahr für Leibleben. Tatsächlich irgendwie Tötungshandlung. Oder halt Gefahr für den Bestehen des Staates eines Bundeslandes. Also sprich halt größerer Terrorismus. Oder Angriff auf Infrastruktureinrichtungen. Wenn sie davon Kenntnisse halten, dass jemand einen Talsperre vergiften will, dann dürfen sie halt. Aber dann darf der halt nicht nur mal daher geredet haben, sondern sie müssen halt einen konkreten Verdacht haben. Das heißt, dass sie zum Beispiel konkrete Vorbereitungshandlungen beobachtet haben. Oder ähnliche Dinge.
Man muss sich den natürlich auch mal überlegen. Man muss sich wirklich sagen, in so einen Fällen wird wahrscheinlich die übergroße Mehrheit aller Deutschen sagen, das ist auch vollkommen okay. Also wenn ein echter konkreter Verdacht vorliegt und es um eine wirklich lebensbedrohliche Straftat geht, dann würden die meisten Menschen sagen, natürlich könnt ihr hier in diesem Fall so ein Ermittlungsmittel benutzen. Aber es soll eben nicht ausgewertet werden auf so ein alltägliches Mittel wie die Telefonbewachung, die ja standardmäßig dauernd gemacht wird. Ich glaube, das ist ein sehr guter Kompromiss.
Also ich meine, wenn der Richter eine ausführliche Begründung für seine Entscheidung vorlegen muss, ich denke, das ist wahrscheinlich insofern auch ein Gewinn, weil man ihn dann ja nachher auch zur Rechenschaft ziehen kann.
Nee, leider nicht.
Das geht nicht, das ist schade.
Wenn Richter in Deutschland zur Rechenschaft ziehen, das ist eine sehr schwierige Angelegenheit. Also das geht eigentlich nur auf dem Dienstaufsichtswege. Aber es ist tatsächlich so, dass sich ein Richter schon dreimal überlegt, ob er durchwinkt bei so einem schweren Eingriff. Also wir sehen es ja beim großen Lausch-Eingriff. Das ist ja auch so, dass der große Lausch-Eingriff eh nicht hohe Schranken hat. Also dass da tatsächlich ein Richter begründen muss, dass zum Beispiel absehbar ist, dass nicht die Privatsphäre angegriffen bzw. der Kernbereich. Also das ist eh nicht gelagert, nicht ganz so hoch. Aber es ist halt nicht so ein Durchwinken wie für Hausdurchsuchungen oder für die KUF.
Man sieht beim großen Lausch-Eingriff auch, dass das eher passiert. In wirklich großen Fällen wird er angewendet. Und was immer behauptet wird, dass die Schranken so hoch sind, dass es untauglich geworden ist, sieht man einfach nicht.
Hatte Zwischenfragen nebenbei, hat diese Entscheidung heute irgendeine Auswirkung auf die Vorratsdatenspeicherung?
Ja, die, also da waren wir sehr überrascht, dass tatsächlich in dieser Deutlichkeit dazu Stellung genommen wurde. Und zwar haben in der Urteilsbegründung die Richter gesagt, dass das Erstellen von Kommunikationsprofilen, die Erhebung, also die Fortlaufenerhebung von Kommunikationsbegleitdaten, also sprich, wer, mit wem, wann, von wo aus.
Also genau die Vorratsdaten.
Genau, die Vorratsdaten de facto einen massiven Eingriff in Grundrechte darstellen.
Und genau.
Also tatsächlich, die Formulierung war ein schwerwiegender Eingriff, was halt wiederum auch bedeutet, dass so eine Datenerhebung halt nicht pauschal passieren kann. Also wir konnten jetzt natürlich in diesem Urteil jetzt nicht der Vorratsdatenspeicherung vorgreifen, aber wir gehen davon aus, dass nach diesen Sätzen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung dann nicht durchkommen kann.
Gibt es da Äußerungen aus dem Bundesinnenministerium?
Die halten sich da natürlich bedeckt drüber und wollen auch nicht gerne drüber reden.
Stan, wir haben noch extrem viele Leute, die in der Leitung hängen. Ich hoffe, deine Fragen erst mal sind beantwortet. Vielleicht wird der Rest im Laufe der Sendung weiterhin noch beantwortet. Wir haben nämlich auch noch Martin am Telefon. Der kommt aus Karlsruhe und der war heute auch beim Gericht dabei. Der kann uns vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen was erzählen, wie es rundherum gelaufen ist. Vorher machen wir die Nachrichten, weil es ist halb elf. Dir erst mal vielen Dank nach Greifswald. Und danach reden wir weiter am Chaosradio auf Fritz über die heutige Entscheidung vom Bundesverfassungsgericht, über die Online-Durchsuchung, die in dem Fall, kann man sagen, dezent gekippt wurde. So könnte man das frech schon mal formulieren. Ich glaube schon, dass man dazu machen kann. Man möge mir das nachsehen. Wir freuen uns auf jeden Fall. Und jetzt gibt es gleich die Nachrichten. Philipp? Ja, Philipp sagt, wir können die Nachrichten machen. All klar, gleich die Info. Und danach geht es weiter mit Martin und mit Frank und mit Daniel und mit vielen anderen. Was kann man noch sagen über einen Mann, der wirklich alles hat?
Das ist ja nett.
Damit habe ich ja jetzt gar nicht geregt.
Gutes Aussehen.
Erfolg bei den Frauen.
Na ja, ich sag mal, gelernt ist gelernt. Und immer einen guten Spruch aufklagern.
Spruch?
Über so einen Mann könnte man viel sein.
Aber hier geht es jetzt um ihn.
Dich.
Mich?
Timo, dein Leben ist herrlich. Die Comedy Novella auf Fritz Fritz.
Immer wochentags um 7 Uhr.
Und 17.10 Uhr.
Und als Podcast auf fritz.de.
Aber jetzt will ich endlich mal jemanden grüßen.
Also...
Und das hört man.
Kurz nach halb elf.
Die Berliner Polizei hat am Nachmittag einen Club, der Rockergruppe Bandidos in Reinickendorf durchsucht. 200 Beamte waren im Einsatz. Ein 23 Jahre alter Mann wurde laut Polizei festgenommen. Er soll an einem Überfall auf zwei Männer vor einem Verein aus, der Hells Angels in Charlottenburg beteiligt gewesen sein. Die Täter hatten die Mitglieder des verfeineten Motorradclubs zum Teil schwer verletzt. Die Bundesregierung hat das Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts zu heimlichen Online-Durchsuchungen begrüßt. Die Richter hätten deutlich gemacht, dass der Staat im Kampf gegen terroristische Bedrohungen nicht darauf verzichten könne, sagte ein Regierungssprecher. Auch Datenschützer zeigten sich zufrieden mit der Entscheidung, denn die Sicherheitsbehörden dürfen die Computer von Verdächtigen nur dann ausforschen, wenn überragend wichtige Rechtsgüter wie Menschenleben oder der Bestand des Staates konkret gefährdet sind. Die Durchsuchung muss von einem Richter angeordnet werden. Eine Überfallserie auf fünf Supermärkte in Berlin-Neukölln ist so gut wie aufgeklärt. Die Polizei hat drei mutmachtliche Täter geschnappt, sucht aber noch nach weiteren. Ein 19-Jähriger sitzt in U-Haft, seine beiden 18-jährigen Komplizen kamen gegen Auflagen wieder frei. Die Männer sollen seit November Supermarktkassen ausgeräumt haben. Im Kampf gegen Steuerhinterziehung will das Fürstentum Monaco mit den deutschen Behörden zusammenarbeiten. Das hat Fürst Albert von Monaco heute bei einem Treffen mit Kanzlerin Merkel versprochen. In Zukunft sollen Infos, zum Beispiel über Steuerbetrug und Geldwäsche, besser untereinander ausgetauscht werden. Ähnlich wie Lichtenstein gilt Monaco als Steueroase. Dort müssen Ausländer so gut wie keine Steuern zahlen, wenn sie ihren Wohnsitz im Fürstentum anmelden. Im Viertelfinale des DFB-Pokals haben sich Wolfsburg und Hamburg gegenüber gestanden. Gewonnen hat Gastgeber Wolfsburg mit 2 zu 1 nach Verlängerung und steht damit im Halbfinale. Die aktuellen Temperaturen, Potsdam 4 Grad, Neuropin, Angermünde und Frankfurt melden 5 Grad, Cottbus, Wittenberge und Berlin melden 7 Grad. Heute Abend bleibt es bewölkt mit einzelnen Regenschauern. Dazu wird es recht stürmisch. In der Nacht soll es dann meist trocken bleiben. Das Ganze bei Temperaturen zwischen 4 und 1 Grad. Morgen erwarten uns wieder viele Wolken, die sich ab und zu aber auch mal verziehen. Es soll trocken bleiben bei 8 bis 11 Grad. A13 Schönefelder Kreuz, Richtung Dresden. Zwischen Mittenwalde und Groß-Köres gab es einen Unfall. Bitte fahrt langsam. A19 Rostock, Richtung Wittstock-Dosse. Zwischen Waren und dem Dreieck Wittstock-Dosse fährt ein Schwertransport, den ihr nicht überholen könnt. Gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des AirBB.
Und wenn im Radio 89, 85, dann Fritz im Berliner Kabel.
Constanze, Frank und Erdgeist sind da. Ich bin auch da. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Wir haben Chaosradio Teil 132. Die Herrschaften sind quasi live aus Karlsruhe direkt hierher geflogen. Man ist ja trotzdem als ob du fliegst. Erdgeist wedelt mit Luftballons, so aufgeregt ist er. Und in Karlsruhe war auch der Martin, der dich angerufen hat. Hallo Martin. Du warst heute beim Bundesverfassungsgericht auch, oder wie?
Nein, das ist leider falsch rübergekommen. Ich wäre furchtbar gerne da gewesen. Ich war bei der Eröffnungsveranstaltung, bei der Reinhörung.
Dann hast du aber das Pferd trotzdem gesehen.
Ja, das Pferd hab ich gesehen. Ich hab mich sogar daneben gestellt.
Für alle, die nicht wissen, was für ein Pferd, Martin, erklär das mal.
Ein ganz wunderbarer großer Holzstrojaner, den der CCC Karlsruhe gebastelt hat in Tropia.
Nein, das war nicht der CCC Karlsruhe.
Das war nicht der CCC Karlsruhe.
Das waren wir hier in Berlin.
Muss man für das strojanische Pferd?
Das ist ein Reisetrojaner.
Per Mail verschickt. Muss man eine eigene Fahrkarte lösen?
Es gibt noch andere Mietwagenfirmen.
Die gelben und die blauen und die roten. Martin, wie hast du das erlebt heute?
Heute war ich nicht da, aber ich hab natürlich alles mitverfolgt und hab's heute schon ganz groß gefeiert. Mein neues Grundrecht. Ich hab alle Blogs gelesen, alle Nachrichten mitverfolgt, was die ganzen Zeitungen schreiben. Bin auch morgen gespannt, was noch in der Presse steht. Ihr habt mir jetzt mein schönstes Stichwort schon weggenommen.
Ich hab nämlich die Auswirkung auf die Vorratsdatensprechung interessiert, weil ja mit diesem neuen Grundrecht, heißt im Urteil auch, dass die Umstände nicht abgehört werden dürfen.
Frank hat es ja ganz kurz angerissen. Vielleicht können wir das noch mal ein bisschen detaillierter beschreiben. Also Vorratsdatenspeicherung wurde kritisiert vom Bundesverfassungsgericht, aber die endgültige Entscheidung darüber, ob die, warum höre ich mich eigentlich doppelt, ist ja merkwürdig, die endgültige Entscheidung darüber, ob die Vorratsdatenspeicherung jetzt rechtswidrig ist oder nicht ist, noch nicht gefallen. Also es werden weiterhin Daten gespeichert.
Ja und die Richter haben natürlich auch nicht die Vorratsdatenspeicherung explizit erwähnt, aber sie haben in der Urteilsbegründung eben über Art und Umfang von Telekommunikation gesprochen und dass dieses eben innerhalb dieses neuen Grundrechts umfasst sei und entsprechend kann man sich natürlich überlegen, wie jetzt im März, wenn die Eilentscheidung zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung kommen wird, dass es vielleicht Einfluss haben wird. Sie haben natürlich dazu nichts konkret gesagt. Man musste natürlich reininterpretieren.
Was könnte da bei dieser Entscheidung passieren? Hast du da schon irgendwas gelesen?
Wir hoffen natürlich auch, dass die Vorratsdatenspeicherung gekippt wird, denn dieses Projekt ist ja im Grunde eigentlich noch monströser, da der vollkommen verdachtlos, also anders unabhängig ist und von allen Bürgern eben die Telekommunikationsverbindungsdaten aufgezeichnet werden. Ich kann mir ehrlich gesagt nicht vorstellen, wie dieses mit dem neuen Grundrecht irgendwie in Einklang zu bringen ist, aber eigentlich auch nicht mit anderen Rechten. Da sind jetzt die Berufsfreiheit dabei. Also ich denke, das wird gekippt werden.
Wir haben ja heute schon beim Thema Bundestrojaner so ein paar leichte kriminal-technische Formulierungen angeschnitten, die dann so bedeuten, es muss ein konkreter Verdacht vorliegen auf eine konkrete Bedrohung und so weiter und so fort. Ich bin nun absolut kein Jurist und bin da total auf dünnem Eis. Kann man es folgstimmig so formulieren, dass der normale Mensch an sich da jetzt also relativ wenig zu befürchten hat, wenn er also nicht unbedingt Strafratten plant oder so? Kann man das so formulieren, Frank, oder ist das jetzt zu einfach?
Also wenn du jetzt nicht planst, irgendwelche Dinge in die Luft zu sprengen, dann bist du eigentlich nicht in der Regel nicht betroffen.
Hatt ich eigentlich nicht vor, nee.
Weiß ja nicht, heute Leute so viele Hobbys haben.
Manchmal Finanzamt denkt man schon.
Martin ist deine Frage mit der Vorratssattenspeicherung damit ein Jahrmaß mal beantwortet.
Ja, die Frage ist beantwortet. Ich hab noch eine zweite Sache.
Dachte ich mir.
Es ist zwar jetzt fantastisch, dass wir dieses neue Grundrecht haben und dass alles so gelaufen ist, wie es gelaufen ist, aber es ist die Frage, wessen Verdienst es jetzt ist. Also es gab ja wahnsinnige Bemühungen, die eine online-Forschung zu verhindern. Es gab ja Demonstrationen, Freiheit statt Angst und so weiter. AK-Vorratszeiten, Speicherung, die ganzen verbundenen Gruppen und Netzwerke.
Ich möchte mal dazwischen kurz fragen, ist es überhaupt ein Diskussionspunkt, jetzt rauszukriegen, wer sich diesen Verdienst an die Brust kleben kann?
Warum nicht?
Es ist die Frage, ob wir ein Problem haben, wenn die letzte Barriere tatsächlich das Bundesverfassungsgericht ist, weil die Politik ja weiterhin ihre Gesetze beschließt.
Das ist vollkommen richtig, dass das so ist. Also, sag mal, die Aussage, die man über den Status der Bundesrepublik Deutschland treffen kann, die daraus resultiert ist, ist halt eine ziemlich dramatische. Nämlich, dass wir de facto eine dysfunktionale Politik haben. Also diese Leute, diese Internet-Ausdrucker da, die halt unsere Regierung stellen, die sind halt tatsächlich nicht in der Lage, irgendwie sinnvolle Dinge zu beschließen. Also auch die handwerkliche Qualität dieser Gesetze ist unter aller Sau. Die Art und Weise, wie die zustande kommen, hat nichts mehr mit Demokratie zu tun. Die einzelnen Abgeordneten können da de facto nichts mehr bewegen und auch nicht mehr nach ihrem Gewissen abstimmen, sondern sind immer unter Fraktionszwang. Und am Ende wird halt alles nur nach politischem Tageskalkül entschieden. Insofern ist das halt eine ziemlich dramatische Ansage über den Status der Politik in Deutschland. Was jetzt den Verdienst betrifft, ich denke schon, dass die Demonstrationen und auch die sonstigen Aktivitäten sehr viel dazu beigetragen haben, den Richtern zu vermitteln, dass sie tatsächlich für die Generation, also unsere Generation, die tatsächlich in diesen Computern lebt, eine völlig andere Bedeutung hat, als für die Schäubleis dieser Welt, die sich nicht mal vorstellen können, wie ein Computer funktioniert und die Internet nur mit Chauffeur benutzen. Also die Arten...
Was ist nochmal ein Browser?
Genau. So, und diese... Also muss man den Verfassungsrichtern hoch anrechnen, dass sie da tatsächlich zugehört haben. Und gut, also der Chaos Computer Club hat da eine Stellungnahme von Andreas Bog mit abgegeben. Professor Fitzmann hat eine sehr gute Stellungnahme abgegeben. Und ich denke mal, auch diese, die Aktivitäten zur Vorarztansprechung und so weiter haben einfach klar gemacht, dass das halt nicht zu ignorieren ist. Sondern dass sich plötzlich da draußen die Realität geändert hat in den letzten Jahren. Und die verfassungsrechtlichen, also die verfassungsgrundsätze dem angepasst werden müssen, im positiven Sinne.
Wobei bei dem ganzen Hurra, was wir jetzt gesagt haben, gibt es auch kritische Stimmen. Martin, ich würde jetzt das Wort von dir weitergeben an Daniel, weil wir haben heute einen extremen Anrang am Telefon. Tschüss nach Karlsruhe, vielen Dank. Und hallo nach Berlin, hallo Daniel.
Ja, hallo, hallo, bin ich das jetzt?
Ich weiß nicht, bist du Daniel?
Ja, ich bin Daniel.
Alles klar. Daniel, du rufst aus Berlin an?
Ja, genau, ich ruf aus Berlin an.
Hab ich jetzt gerade eher geraten, aber herzlich willkommen im Chaosradio. Du siehst die ganze Geschichte eher kritisch, wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe.
Ich möchte auf jeden Fall meine Gegenstimme aufmachen. Alle sind jetzt so glücklich darüber, dass das heute abgeschmettert wurde, aber es wurden von euch auch in den letzten 10 Minuten, ich habe ja schon seit 15 Minuten am Warteschleife, Sachen aufgemacht, die eigentlich dafür sprechen, dass das heute nicht hätte abgeschmettert werden sollen. Einer der ersten Fragen von einem Kollegen, von dem er mich vorher dran genommen hat, so vorzutesten, hast du Sachen auf deinem Computer, die du nicht von anderen einsehen lassen willst, wo du das nicht möchtest, sage ich natürlich. Dann kam wesentlich später oder vor ganz kurzem die Frage von euch da in eurer Runde. Warte mal, ob das denn okay wäre, wenn... Also was hast du mit deinen Daten vor? Hat der dich, glaube ich, gefragt. Und du sagst, ich will keine Luft springen.
Natürlich nicht.
Dann hast du auch nichts zu befürchten. Und das ist irgendwie das ganze Spektrum. Wir haben alle Daten auf unserem Computer, die wir nicht von anderen einsehen lassen wollen, auf der anderen Seite glaube ich auch, dass wir ebenfalls alle oder die große Mehrheit eben nicht die Absicht haben, mit unseren Internetverbindungen, Daten auf unseren Computern irgendwelchen Menschen zu schaden.
Ganz genau. Das würde ich jetzt hoffentlich auch so unterschreiben, dass die große Mehrheit von uns das so plant. Aber damit sind wir ja genau bei der Geschichte, die das Bundesverfassungsgericht heute auch festgestellt hat, was Frank eben auch so schön formuliert hat, dass dieses Gesetz jetzt im Internet-Zeitalter angekommen ist, dass Leute wie du, ich, wir alle, die wir sehr viel mit dem Computer arbeiten, da Dateien drauf speichern und das nicht immer nur ausdrucken und in den Schrank heften, dass es für uns ein ganz anderes Arbeitsmaterial, Arbeitsmittel und damit auch ein Stück Privatsphäre ist, wo wir bitte zu entscheiden haben, wer darauf Zugriff hat und wer nicht, ob das jetzt Fotos von deiner Freundin sind oder deine Steuererklärung oder Fotos von, was weiß ich, einem Unfall, die du mit dem Fahrrad hattest, was du der Versicherung schicken musst, das ist in dem Fall ja vollkommen irrelevant.
Aber die Planung, die das Bundesministerium hatte und was halt auch das Bundeskriminalamt und ähnliche tatsächlich gerne wollten, war halt ein sehr viel weitergehender Zugriff. Was die halten wollten, die wollten, wenn sie irgendwie so einen Wagenverdacht haben, dann wollten sie gleich mit den großen Kanonen ausrücken.
Ich glaube nicht nach Wagenverdacht.
Doch, wir haben ja vor ein paar Sendungen hier den einen jungen Mann gehabt, der genau von so einem Wagenverdacht betroffen war. Der halt auf der Grundlage von ein paar Worten in einem Artikel plötzlich als Terrorist verdächtigt wurde. Und gegen den sie das komplette Programm gefahren haben. Und wenn sie zu dem Zeitpunkt schon das Recht für eine Online-Desisierung gehabt hätten, dann hätten sie das tatsächlich bei dem auch durchgeführt. Und dass das Bundesverfassungsgericht jetzt klarstellt, dass ja, wenn es wirklich um schweren Terrorismus geht, dann dürft ihr unter engen Voraussetzungen. Aber ansonsten dürft ihr nicht. Ist tatsächlich ein sehr weises Urteil, weil sie sagen, den Ermittlern sind damit nicht komplett alle Mittel aus der Hand geschlagen.
Ja, lass es doch bei den engen Voraussetzungen bleiben. Also damit bin ich ja völlig einverstanden.
Die haben wir doch heute erst bekommen.
Die haben wir heute erst bekommen, die waren vorher nicht in der Diskussion.
Die waren einfach nicht vorhanden.
Also Schäuble hat immer gerne diese Beispiele gemacht.
Oder ihr habt vorhin auch über Lauschangriff im Gegensatz zu einer normalen Telefonabhörmaßnahme. Ihr behauptet, eine Telefonabhörmaßnahme wäre sehr leicht einzurichten.
Also die Anzahl…
Aber die braucht auch einen richterlichen Beschluss, oder?
Ja, das ist aber ein Formular, was abgestempelt und unterschrieben wird.
Das heißt, das macht ein Amtsrichter. Das bedeutet auch, dass er etwa in einem Bundesland wie Bayern nur ein paar Minuten… Zwei. Nein, das war die Hausdurchsuchung. Also ein paar Minuten hat, um das zu unterschreiben. Und wir haben Fälle, die gehen in einem Jahr betrachtet auf 100.000 Betroffene. Das heißt, wir sind nicht nur relativ, sondern auch absoluter Weltmeister im Abhören von Telefonen. Das ist eine Standardermittlungsmaßnahme. Die wird durchgewunken. Und es ging uns im Vorfeld dieses Urteils insbesondere darum, dass bei so einem intensiven Eingang, dass jemand die Festplatte abschnorchelt, andere Frausitzungen gelten als für diese Sachen wie Internet überwachen oder Telefon überwachen. Das ist einfach auch für eine Gesellschaft, die in eine digitale Zeit geht, einfach von höchster Präsenz.
Heute muss ein Richter dann einen Gutachten schreiben.
Ja, er muss eingehend prüfen und es muss eine Kernbereichsprognose geben.
Ich glaube, wir sind jetzt sehr, sehr tief im juristischen Dschungel.
Ja, es ist einfach zu verstehen.
Weil es ist natürlich keine einfache Entscheidung und es ist kein Schwarz und Weiß. Aber ich sehe schon irgendwo die Wahrheit zwischen dem Richter, der wahrscheinlich mehrere Tage, wenn nicht Wochen braucht, um so eine Begründung zu schreiben, um diese Art von Überwachung zuzulassen, gegenüber dem, was ich jetzt zum ersten Mal höre, der Telefonabwehrmaßnahme, wo er nur zwei Minuten braucht.
Wobei ich das alles schon ein bisschen tendenziell finde.
Na, du kannst dir die Statistiken zur Telefonüberwachung jedes Jahr bei der Bundesnetzagentur runterladen.
In der Summe, unterm Strich, mehr Menschen geschadet oder mehr Menschen geholfen?
Geschadet.
Geschadet. Das kann man einfach pauschal so sagen.
Wieso wegen dem Eingriff in deren Privatsphäre?
Nein, weil man sich die Zahlen ansehen kann, wie viele Telefonüberwachung tatsächlich zu einem Verfahren führen und dann zu einem Urteil. Und da sind wir bei nicht mehr 25 Prozent. Das heißt, dass über drei Viertel der Leute einfach mal abgeschnorchelt werden, weil sie eben abgeschnorchelt werden, nicht, weil sie eine Straftat begangen haben, für die sie verurteilt werden.
Du musst dir den Schaden einfach so vorstellen, dass wenn du am Ende nicht mehr telefonierst, ohne die über die Schulter zu gucken und überlegst, wer denn jetzt alles mithört, weil du weißt, dass da eh in sechs-siebenstelliger Anzahl deine Telefonbesprecher abgehört werden, dann hast du dich ja in eine Richtung verändert, die dir vielleicht auch nicht so gefallen würde. Also der Schaden an deiner Freiheit an...
Ich finde mir das nicht nur reaktionär, sondern auch noch darüber hinaus naiv. Aber ich habe nichts zu verbergen, weißt du?
Ja, gut, dann hast du, aber das ist aber dein Problem.
Ein langweiliges Leben, also wenn nicht zu verbergen, hat er wirklich...
Wenn du nichts zu verbergen hast, fein, das ist schön für dich.
Also warte mal, warte mal, Moment mal. Moment mal, also ehe wir jetzt alle anfangen, uns auf einer persönlichen Ehe zu bewegen...
Nein, ich meine, man kann das sagen. Jeder Person hat das Recht.
Aber jetzt mal also diese ganzen persönlichen Geschichten hin und her, ich würde das gerne mal wieder ein bisschen glattbügeln wollen. Daniel hat an dem Punkt natürlich schon Recht, auch wenn es mit der Telefonüberwachung jetzt neu für ihn war, dass ein Großteil der Menschen natürlich sagt, ich habe doch nichts zu befürchten. Und das, was mit der Online-Durchsuchung geplant war, dass man einfach, was du auch gerade gesagt hast, Constanze, dass man quasi mit dem Salzstreuer oder mit dem Gießkannenprinzip erstmal guckt, was überall passiert, um dann Sachen weiter rauszuziehen, dass dem jetzt durch die Entscheidung vom Bundesverfassungsgericht heute mehrere Hürden auferlegt werden, die nicht so einfach zu übergehen sind, wo jeder von uns sich in seiner eigenen Privatsphäre und auch seiner neuen, so schön genannten digitalen Intimität, wo wir ja ein neues Grundrecht drauf haben, ein bisschen sicherer fühlen kann. Und im Endeffekt, ob Daniel das auf der einen Seite so sieht, oder wir auf der anderen Seite, sind wir auf dem selben Level.
Es ist ja wirklich tatsächlich so, dass viele Leute sagen, ich habe nicht wirklich was zu verbergen, und ich traue diesem Staat in gewisser Weise. Aber man muss natürlich dabei überlegen, dass man diese Denken nicht auf andere Menschen übertragen kann. Nur weil man selber von sich glaubt, dass man nichts zu verbergen hat, darf man wohl nicht von den anderen Menschen verlangen, dass sie genauso denken.
Das könnten wir dann weiter diskutieren, wenn Daniel noch mal am Telefon ist.
Ein Punkt dazu noch, was ich sehr bemerkenswert fand, ist, dass die Diskussion um den Bundestrojaner zu einer massiven Mobilisierung der digitalen Generation geführt hat. Das heißt also, da sind eine Menge Leute, denen die Telefonüberwachung einigermaßen egal war, passiert halt so. Wenn es aber darum geht, den Leuten auf die Festplatte zu gucken, dann werden viele Leute plötzlich sehr sensibel, weil die wissen, dass de facto ihr gesamtes Leben auf dieser Platte ist.
Von Fotos über Steuererklärungen bis hin zu Bedarfungsschreiben und sonst was.
Genau. Das heißt also, natürlich, wenn man irgendwie ein Leben mit Aktenordnern führt, dann ist einem nicht egal, nur sein Computer als Schreibmaschine benutzt. Aber wenn man tatsächlich, wie wir halt, in diesem Internet lebt und da den größten Teil seiner Kommunikationsbeziehungen hat und irgendwie Sachen darüber bucht, Hotels und dergleichen Dinge mehr, Reisen und so weiter, und Dating-Sites benutzt und was die Leute heutzutage alles damit tun, dann ist der Eingriff in das private Leben sehr viel schwerwiegender und wird auch als sehr viel schwerwiegender empfunden. Der interessante Punkt war, dass es in sehr vielen Leuten so ging. Also diese Kampagne gegen den Bundestrojaner war die Kampagne, wo wir am meisten Resonanz bisher überhaupt hatten. Also wo einfach Leute aus Ecken kamen, wo wir niemals damit gerechnet hätten, dass die sagen, okay, das geht nun wirklich nicht. Da ist die rote Linie, da geht es jetzt nicht mehr weiter.
Und eigentlich ist es auch, was die Richter heute gesagt haben. Die Richter sprachen in der Urteilsbegründung davon, dass man durch den Zugriff auf eine Platte ein Persönlichkeitsprofil bilden kann. Einfach tief in einen Menschen hineinschauen kann. Mit allen Aspekten, Hobbys, berufliche Zeug. Die haben das sehr klar herausgestellt, dass es darum geht, dass es hier einen Schutzbereich gibt.
Ich finde ja höchst interessant, dass es auch eine Äußerung gab zum Thema Vorratsdatenspeicherung, was uns dann wahrscheinlich in diesem Jahr in den kommenden Sendungen beschäftigen wird. Aber wir graben erst mal weiter hier am Telefon. Wet Sniper ist dran. Hallo, guten Abend. Oh, da ist aber jemand äußerst motiviert. Tagchen, darfst du sagen, von wo du anrufst? Aus Wuppertal, grüße dich.
Ich hätte auch schon mal angerufen, Wet Cypher ist aber richtig.
Hier steht es, Wet Cypher. Na, wie dem auch immer sei. Was sagst du denn zu dem Urteil heute?
Ja, ich habe mir das Ganze auf Live auf Phoenix angesehen. Ich habe erstmal die letzten Sekunden etwas kribbeln und dann erstmal groß gefeiert. Ich sag mal, ich kenne das von meinem Landgericht Wuppertal mal selber als Besucher ab und zu. Da erkenne ich die Atmosphäre, wie man da so reinkommt. Ektro, sprich Metalldetektor und dergleichen. Aber bei mir haben sich so ein paar Fragen selber aufgetan.
Dann schließt es los, vielleicht können wir die ja diskutieren.
Ja und zwar, einerseits so die Sache, das Ganze ist ja schon öfters Sachen passiert, die verfassungswidrig sind. Und im Prinzip ist es ja nicht das erste Mal. Es passiert ja offensichtlich öfters. Und warum ist zum Beispiel der Herr Schäuble immer noch Bundesinnenminister? Stellen sich ja viele Leute die Frage.
Das können wir hier weder wir noch das Bundesverfassungsgericht beantworten, die Frage.
Also die, sag mal, die, die, die wird jetzt gerade von den Politikern, wo der sich auf anspürzt, die zur Schau getragene gute Mine von Zirkus und Schäuble, hat natürlich einfach damit zu tun, dass sie halt in ihrer Lage nicht zugeben können. Insbesondere, weil das Bundesverfassungsgericht halt ihre Argumentation, dass sie es in wenigen wirklich schwersten Fällen benötigen, dieses Mittel, einfach beim Wort genommen hat. Also die haben halt einfach die beim Wort genommen und gesagt, ok, ihr braucht es in wirklich harten Fällen, das sehen wir ein, dann kriegt ihr halt ordentliche Schranken davor, um dafür zu sorgen, dass ihr es genau nur in diesen Fällen benutzt.
Die generelle Frage ist, sind ja schon öfters verfassungswidrige Sachen gelaufen, immer wieder abgeblockt worden, ist die Frage, warum muss das immer zum Bundesverfassungsgericht gehen? Warum kann nicht in einer Vorinstanz schon gesagt werden, warum kann das nicht erst mal erst geprüft werden? Weil jetzt hat man ja gesagt, den Bundestrojaner, den lassen wir jetzt einfach mal frei. Und das wird jetzt im Nachhinein erst geprüft.
Das Problem liegt einfach daran, dass das System der politischen Entscheidungsfindung in Deutschland mittlerweile so dermaßen verkommen ist, dass es nicht mehr in der Lage ist, solche Entscheidungen zu fällen. Das kann man einfach so zusammenfassen. Es ist einfach nicht mehr so, dass die parlamentarische Demokratie in der Lage ist, rationale Sachentscheidungen zu fällen, in Abwägung von verfassungsmäßigen Grundsätzen. Und de facto finden halt die inhaltlichen Vorarbeiten auf der ministeriellen Ebene statt, und die werden halt parteipolitisch geschert und dann entsprechend durchgewunken. Und de facto hat sich die Politik damit abgefunden, dass solche Gesetze halt einmal nach Karlsruhe gehen und dann da vielleicht irgendwie abgewunken oder abgewählt werden. Der Zustand ist halt extrem beklagenswert. Ich sage mal, bis irgendwie neue Generationen in den politischen Parteien angekommen sind oder das jetzige Personal halt einfach mal sich in die Rente verabschiedet, wird sich da vermutlich nichts daran erinnern, vielleicht unterhalb von der Revolution.
Du könntest ja einfach mal folgenden Spaß dir machen. Du könntest ja mal mit zwei Tassen Kaffee zu deinem örtlichen... Bundesratabgeordneten?... Landesverband von der CDU gehen oder zu deinem Landtagsabgeordneten und einfach genau da diese Frage stellen. Sagen, ich habe einen Kaffee mitgebracht, habt ihr mal eine Viertelstunde Zeit. Ich hätte mal gerne ein paar Fragen, die würde ich gerne geklärt haben. Weil ich glaube, hier an dieser Stelle werden wir da auf keinen Punkt weiterkommen. Du hast gesagt, du hast eine Menge Fragen. Was brennt dir denn noch auf der Seele?
Genau, da wollte ich mich gerade hinkommen. Ich wollte jetzt auch ein bisschen kappen, nicht, dass du so klatschst, weil... Ja, und zwar der Bundestrojaner. Der fand ja, bevor das... Ich sag mal, die haben im Prinzip den Bundestrojaner gehabt, der kam zum Einsatz, und dann haben die erst gesagt, jetzt möchten wir ein Gesetz dazu haben. Das fand ja schon öfters statt. Hat das irgendwelche Folgen, weil das ist jetzt verfassungswidrig erkannt worden, hat das irgendwelche Folgen für irgendwelche Beteiligten, dass die da im Prinzip schon vorher, ich sag mal, eine ganze Zeit den Bundestrojaner damit rumgespielt haben.
Auch die Frage wären wir dir wahrscheinlich hier nicht beantworten können.
Na doch, man kann die insofern beantworten, dass natürlich das Gesetz, was heute besprochen wurde, nichts mit dem Bundestrojaner, der auf Bundesebene vom damaligen Innenminister Otto Schiedi erlaubt wurde, zu tun hat. Der hat eine Dienstanweisung gegeben, und letztes Jahr hat der Bundesgerichtshof bereits entschieden, so geht das nicht, es gibt keine Rechtsgrundlage für die Polizei. Das ist aber ganz unabhängig von dem Gesetz, was heute in Karlsruhe verhandelt wurde. Und natürlich gibt es schon eine Möglichkeit, wie diese falsche Dienstanweisung quasi geahndet werden könnte, etwa mit einem parlamentarischen Untersuchungsausschuss. Aber das ist nicht wirklich eine Strafe im Sinne von, er kriegt jetzt irgendwie ein Urteil und eine Strafe.
Nein, nein, das ist ja noch nicht die Woche, dass er irgendwelche, insofern irgendwelche Folgen hat.
Er muss die Strafe dreimal sein Windows neu aufsetzen.
Und jetzt noch die, das ist jetzt auch ein bisschen Metafragen mäßig.
Komm mal, weil die anderen waren ja auch keine Metafragen.
Wie weit, die Fälle, die sind jetzt abgeschlossene Verhandlung, inwieweit wird das selber bekannt gegeben? Weil es gibt ja irgendwie so eine Regelung von wegen, was ist und dann nichts mehr, wenn die...
Also du meinst die Benachrichtigung im Nachhinein. Die ist tatsächlich auch vorgesehen worden.
Benachrichtigung im Nachhinein heißt kurz erklärt...
Wenn sie halt durch die Festplatte geschnorchelt sind, müssen sie hinterher Bescheid sagen, sobald es halt irgendwie geht. Also das Verfahren abgeschlossen ist oder eingestellt oder was auch immer.
Damit du halt die Möglichkeit hast, überhaupt Rechtsschutz einzulegen, muss ich ja irgendwie wehren können, sonst weißt du es ja nicht mehr.
Und das ist halt so, dass es in der Praxis halt sehr stumpf ist und zu dem man auch sehr zweischneidig und schwer ist. Wir sind halt bei der Telekommunikationsüberwachung. Das ist halt so, dass nur ein sehr geringer Teil der tatsächlich Betroffenen überhaupt benachrichtigt wird und dass die Folgen für die, die dann benachrichtigt werden, teilweise ziemlich katastrophal sind, weil die dann halt all ihren Freunden erzählen müssen, naja, die haben mich halt im letzten Halbjahr abgehört und deine Telefonatter waren halt auch dabei. Das ist halt, naja, wie als wenn man mit einer ansteckenden Krankheit diagnostiziert wird und irgendwie alle seine Freunde angesteckt hat. Also das ist halt eine sehr, sehr schwerwiegende Geschichte für die Leute. Also der Strafanwälte, mit dem wir halt viel zu tun haben, sagen uns halt auch, diese Benachrichtigungspflicht, so ist halt auf dem Papier schön und gut, aber a, wird sie halt kaum angewendet, die finden halt immer einen Grund, nicht Bescheid zu sagen, und b, sind die Folgen von Betroffenen halt ziemlich dramatisch. Was jetzt tatsächlich im konkreten Fall passieren wird, ist halt schwer zu sagen, also jetzt beim Trojaner-Einsatz, die Anzahl der Fälle wird halt ding durch die Schranken sehr gering sein. Insofern bleibt es halt abzuwarten, kann man ja bisher noch nicht sagen.
Bei mir würden jetzt, sag ich mal, Bewerbungsunterlagen, Fotos, Passwörter auch halt eben für E-Mail, Router, Messenger und dergleichen andere.
Na, was man eben so hat an Dingens.
Ja, ich sag mal, in dem Sinne besteht ja auch eben auch die Gefahr, Bundestrojaner, ist die Frage, wie sicher der wirklich, sag ich mal, ist. Weil ich sag mal, die Bundesregierung benutzt den jetzt, aber der kann ja auch irgendwie manipuliert werden odergleichen, dass da irgendwie Missbrauch von auch anderen, die dann wirklich kriminelle Dinge damit rumdrehen.
Schau doch einfach mal bei dir zu Hause auf deinen Computer, was da für Programme installiert hast, wie oft die abstürzen. Und das ist so die durchschnittliche Softwarequalität da draußen. Du überlegst dir, wenn du irgendeine Klitsche für die Bundesregierung, den Bundestrojaner baut, wie dann wohl da die Softwarequalität aussieht und wer da noch alles rein kann, wie oft die Rechner da abstürzen. Insbesondere spannend, wenn man sich überlegt, dass ja eigentlich in dem Gesetz in Nordrhein-Westfalen nicht nur gefordert wurde, dass da Rechner, sondern die ganze informationstechnische Systeme, zu denen auch so Dinge gehören. Also bei uns hatte sich ein Hörbehinderter gemeldet, der meinte, ich hab da so ein Hörgerät, das ist wieder ein ausgefeilter Computer. Was ist denn jetzt? Können die da auch irgendwie Software installieren und mich dann so abhören? Und genau in dem Moment wird es auch ganz doll spannend, weil das ausgelerrerte Gehirn dann auch von der anderen Seite von Menschen, die auch wirklich Computer schon benutzen, um ihre Lebensqualität zu verbessern, weil sie halt behindert sind oder andere Menschen, die das einfach nur tun wollen, weil sie keine Ahnung, besser sehen oder besser hören wollen, dass die plötzlich auch informationstechnische Systeme mit sich rumschleppen, auf die dann nach dem Gesetz auch bundestrojaner installiert werden könnte. Und wenn du dann plötzlich ein abgestürztes Programm in deinem Augen, in deinem Hörhilfen hast, dann hast du ein ganz schlimmes Problem.
Also das Verfassungsgericht hat diese Gefahren sehr klar benannt. Was sie halt gesagt haben ist, okay, das Mittel ist halt nicht nur von der Eingriffstiefe, sondern auch von dem Risiko von Nebenwirkungen halt so drastisch, dass es halt eine echte Notmaßnahme sein muss. Also es muss halt so sein, dass der Notfall de facto so gravierend ist, dass das dann auch egal ist. Also was halt die Schwelle schon sehr hoch liegt, weil im Zweifel können halt durch abstotzende Computermenschen umkommen.
Es ist ja eigentlich so, es ist ja nicht nur nichtig erklärt worden, weil es eben nicht angemessen ist, sondern eigentlich gibt es drei verschiedene Gründe, die sie heute genannt haben, weswegen dieses Gesetz schon mal nichtig ist. Das ist einmal Bestimmtheitsgebot, da ist es nicht mal klar gesagt, was eigentlich alles gemeint ist, sondern eben die totale Generalermichtigung. Der zweite ist die Normenklarheit. Also da steht eigentlich nicht mal deutlicherweise drin, was gemeint ist. Und der dritte ist halt die Angemessenheit. Also es ist nicht angemessen für den Zweck. Und da sind eigentlich drei schallende Ohrfeigen.
Ich habe das ja so halt insgesamt verfolgt. Das ist zumindest am Anfang irgendwie nicht richtig klar. Was ist jetzt im Prinzip genau der Bundesverfassungsgericht? Ich meine, ist das jetzt eine Artverform?
Ist das eine Softwareform?
Das ist auch de facto nicht zu beschränken, wenn man sich die Entwicklung anguckt. Sondern es geht tatsächlich um den heimlichen Zugriff auf informationstechnische Systeme in dieser Pauschalität. Das heißt also, wie denn tatsächlich dieser Zugriff passiert, ist nicht festgelegt, nicht definiert. Das kann sich dann die Behörden überlegen.
Die Richter haben die ganze Zeit von Infiltration gesprochen. Das ist ein wirklich schöner Begriff.
Und wenn diese ganze Diskussion um den Bundestrojaner und die Online-Durchsuchung zumindest dahin geführt hat, dass Zehntausende, Hunderttausende, vielleicht Millionen Leute in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland drüber nachgedacht haben, wie sie sich mit ihrem digitalen Leben, ihrer digitalen Intimsphäre, wie es heute schon formuliert wurde, wie sie sich da verhalten und dafür neues Bewusstsein zu schaffen und ihnen zu erklären, dass auch Daten auf einem Rechner nicht unbedingt sicher sind, weil wenn Mittel und Wege eingeleitet werden, kommt man daran. Also wenn dieses Bewusstsein geschaffen ist, dann ist glaube ich schon eine ganze Menge passiert in diesem Land. Und damit ein wunderbarer Oper-Teil.
Ja, okay, ebenso.
Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Letzter Mittwoch im Monat, Chaosradio Teil 132, Erdgeist Frank Constanze sind hier, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz, wir reden über das heutige Urteil vom Bundesverfassungsgericht, dass die Online-Durchsuchung und der sogenannte Bundestrojaner in der Form, wie sie gerne gewollt würden, so nicht durchsetzbar sind, sondern dass ein konkreter Verdacht auf eine konkrete Bedrohung bestehen muss, um diese Mittel einzusetzen. Das heißt, wie wir es eben in der ersten Stunde schon erwähnt haben, dass die Hürde, diese Mittel einzusetzen, so dermaßen hoch ist, wie sie eigentlich auch von den Leuten, die sie haben wollten, formuliert wurde, dass es heute durchaus als ein guter Tag in Sachen Datensicherung und Datenschutz dleichend werden kann. Stimmt's? Stimmt's. Und damit schninken wir rüber zu Frank. Hallo, Frank. Du musstest jetzt lange warten, aber hier am Telefon ist gerade die Hölle los. Alle Leute freuen sich oder regen sich total auf und wollen sich hier im Ärger Luft machen. Du bist der nächste. Freust du dich oder ärgerst du dich drüber? Das ist schön.
Und im Endeffekt ist es auch so, das hab ich jetzt irgendwo gelesen, der Computer und alles, was damit zusammen hängt, wird zum Teil der Persönlichkeit erklärt. Und das passt eben zu dem, was eben gesagt hat, die digitale Welt war richtig mehr mobilisiert worden. Und die Richter sind da eben drauf eingegangen und haben eben den Computers zu einem wichtigen Teil meiner Persönlichkeit erklärt. Das find ich gut so.
Bist du jemand, der mit dem Computer auf du und du ist? Also der klingt total nach 1985, aber der schon irgendwie mit dem Rechner lebt und ein Leben ohne Rechner sich nicht vorstellen kann?
Ich kann mir das so ohne Rechner nicht mehr vorstellen. Ich hab das eigentlich seit kleinem angefangen mit damals dem VC20. Und das war eigentlich noch nie anders.
Wo kommst du denn her, Frank?
Aus Leichlingen. Das liegt in Nordrhein-Westfalen.
Oh, bei der Wurzel alles Bösen.
Ja, genau.
Du wirst also in dem Land, wo der Verfassungsschutz dich hätte ausspionieren können.
Theoretisch ja. Wobei, ich finde es jetzt gut, dass die hohen Auflagen da, dass das Gesetz hat, solches jetzt mal so gekippt worden ist. Und das ist immer eine gute Sache. Und die Auflagen, die so hoch sind, sind auch eigentlich ganz positiv. Also ich finde das ganz gut. Ich habe nur die Befürchtung, dass so ein Herrn Schäuble irgendwie wieder so ein Quasi-Verteidigungsfall oder so was einfallen wird, indem man versucht, das wieder auszuhebeln. Und das müsste dann wieder von Verfassungsgericht geklärt werden, dass es eben nicht geht, so wie damals mit den Flugzeugen die Sache da.
Beim Luftsicherheitsgesetz.
Ja, genau, und ich meine, der gute Mann ist sehr kreativ und so was, finde ich. Und da hätte man vielleicht noch klarer machen können, dass das für den Mann, also vom Verfassungsgericht her klarer machen können, dass das für den Mann eine ohrfeige gewesen ist und dass er eben nicht frei hantieren kann, so wie er es mit dem Luftsicherheitsgesetz probiert hat.
Formal ist er natürlich nicht zuständig. Es war ja eigentlich jetzt so, dass der Innenminister von Nordrhein-Westfalen FDP-Mann ist und einer der Kläger ebenfalls, also der ehemalige Bundesminister Gerhard Baum. Genau, da hat ja eigentlich jetzt der Schäuble direkt nichts damit zu tun. Aber es geht natürlich im Hintergrund auch immer darum, dass ja in wenigen Wochen schon der BKA-Gesetzentwurf ins Kabinett gebracht werden soll, dass also darüber entschieden wird, ob auch eben Polizeibehörden online durchsuchen können. Und hier haben sich die Richter auch sehr klar darauf bezogen. Sie haben also gesagt, es geht hier nicht um Geheimdienste nur, sondern es geht auch um die Polizei.
Und da kommen wir jetzt, Frank Wadermeyer. Ich würde ganz kurz Alex mit Ihnen in die Leitung nehmen, der sich ein bisschen vordringelt, aber das passt hervorragend rein. Name ist Alex. Du rufst aus Magdeburg an. Du willst wissen, wie eine Online-Durchsuchung eigentlich abläuft.
Ja, ich hätte halt schon gern gewusst, ob da jetzt konkret einer in seinem Rechner sitzt und dann guckt, was irgendwer anders macht. Oder ob da jetzt auch irgendwie Software-Tools eingesetzt werden, die...
Na, die eigentliche Idee war ja quasi, einen Trojaner per E-Mail zu verschicken. Und dann steht als Absender nicht drauf, mit freundlichen Grüßen dein Bundesinnenministerium, sondern steht irgendwie drauf, ihre Zulassungsstelle oder Steueramt oder so.
Also die tatsächliche technische Durchführung, wie schon erwähnt, wie die denn tatsächlich aussieht, also ob es eine Hardware-Manipulation ist oder ob es eine Software-Manipulation ist oder ob du eine CD kriegst oder sie den Trojaner per Hand installieren oder eine E-Mail ist, die ist tatsächlich offen gelassen. Also es ist nicht so, dass aus diesem Urteil irgendeine Art von Beschränkung des technischen Mittels folgt, sondern es wird nur eine Reihe von technischen Mitteln ausdrücklich erwähnt, zum Beispiel auch elektronische Abstrahlung, also tatsächlich die Belauschung des Monitors. Genau, Keylogger. Dass die halt auch explizit unter diese hohen Schranken fallen. Das heißt also, das Gericht hat halt nicht gesagt, also diese Technologie dürfte er verwenden, diese Technologie dürfte er nicht verwenden, sondern sie hat gesagt, de facto alles, was dazu führt, dass dein Rechner ausgespäht werden kann, fällt unter diese hohen Schranken. Da bleibt sozusagen der Fantasie des BKA überlassen, was sie jetzt genau anwenden.
Da wo ich eigentlich drauf hinaus will, ist eigentlich, wenn wir jetzt von größeren Datenmengen reden, die sie ja auch durchsuchen wollen, mit irgendwelchen Data-Mining-Techniken oder was weiß ich, dann setzen wir ja irgendwelche Software ein. Und das Problem, das ich habe, ist, dass viele Leute, die jetzt auch sagen, sie hätten jetzt nichts zu verbergen, irgendwie anscheinend ein riesengroßes Vertrauen daran haben, dass diese Tools, die da eingesetzt werden, einfach 100% korrekt funktionieren. Und ich finde eigentlich jeder, der selber schon mal irgendwie mit Software zu tun hat oder so...
Erdgeist hat das ja gerade sehr schön formuliert.
Ja, also de facto ist es halt so, dass genau dieser Risikoaspekt ist, den das Verfassungsgericht auch erwähnt hat, dass sie gesagt haben, der Einsatz dieses Werkzeugs ist halt mit hohen Risiken verbunden, egal welche Technologie jetzt verwendet wird, also vielleicht mal mit der Ausnahme von kompromittierenden Emissionen, also elektronischen Abstrahlung, gibt es halt immer die Gefahr, dass das System beeinträchtigt wird und dass halt Kollateralschäden entstehen. Und auch deswegen, das ist einer der Gründe, werden halt die Schranken so hochgelegt.
Wir haben uns eigentlich auch sehr gefreut, dass die Richter einen gewissen Interessenkonflikt explizit erwähnt haben, der daran besteht, dass er zum einen der Ziel der Bundesregierung ist, die Rechner zu sichern, jetzt mal zum Beispiel für die Wirtschaft, dass wir eben möglichst sichere Rechner haben. Und aber auf der anderen Seite eben versuchen wir, Sicherheitslücken auszunutzen für die Ausspionierung. Also diesen Interessenkonflikt, den haben die Richter auch explizit angesprochen.
Das ist sowieso eine Sache, die ich sowieso nicht verstehe, weil teilweise das BSI oder so, die geben wirklich konkrete Tipps auf, wie man seinen Rechner eigentlich absichern soll.
Genau.
Und auf der anderen Seite scheinen andere Bundesminister, die scheinen ja überhaupt nicht miteinander zu sprechen.
Das war ja auch wohl Absicht. Der BSI wurde aus der Sache mal rausgehalten.
Für die Hobbyköcher unter uns, BSI ist das?
Das Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik.
Das Bundesamt, was halt tatsächlich dafür zuständig ist.
Die Zentralstelle für Schöprierweg.
Die geben so CDs raus, auf denen so die Standard-Viren-Scan-Tools umsonst drauf sind und PGP.
Na ja, sie machen halt noch ein bisschen mehr. Die sind halt de facto dafür zuständig, die Bundesbehörden abzusichern, also tatsächlich die Informationstechnik der Bundesbehörden zu sichern. Und betreiben halt auch in größerem Umfang IT-Sicherheitsmaßnahmen, Projekte usw. und so fort. Und da war natürlich von Anfang an klar, dass es da einen Interessenkonflikt gibt. Denen haben sie halt versucht, dadurch zu entschärfen, dass sie das BSI halt da rausgehalten haben. Die sagten, okay, das macht das BKA, das Bundeskriminalamt. Und das BSI bleibt da mal außen vor.
Aber es kann trotzdem immer mal gucken, ob der Virenscanner beim BKA aktuell ist.
Zumal halt das BSI wahrscheinlich am meisten darüber weiß, was gerade an Lücken im Umlauf ist, mit denen halt so ein Eindringen möglich wäre. Insofern, naja, da bleibt halt immer ein Geschmäckle dabei. Und insofern haben die Richter halt auch diesen Interessenkonflikt nochmal explizit betont.
Alex, ich hoffe, die Frage nach der Online-Durchsuchung ist damit beantwortet.
Ja, nee, also finde ich auch sehr gut, dass die, dass wir auch vom Bundesverfassungsgericht auch wirklich darauf eingegangen sind, dass da halt eben nicht dieses Vertrauen in diese Software einfach so da sein kann, weil es halt ein technisches System ist, was per se fehlerbehaftet sein kann.
Na ja, dass es halt nicht immer so funktioniert, wie sie sich das vorstellen. Hat man euch auch gesehen, als die Bundesregierung selber Ziel der Online-Durchsuchung aus China geworden ist. Auch da haben sie es ja am Ende rausgefunden. Und genauso kann man sich vorstellen, dass auch der Bundestrojaner dann entdeckt werden würde. Und dann, wenn Dritte Kenntnis davon erlangen, wie dieser Bundestrojaner funktioniert, dann werden sie natürlich dieselben Sicherheitslücken, über die der Trojaner eingedrungen ist, selber benutzen können oder sogar noch Fehler im Bundestrojaner finden und den benutzen zu eigenen Zwecken.
Tschüss.
So Frank, wir mussten Alex mal kurz dazwischen schieben, weil die Frage jetzt explizit technisch im Raum stand. Können wir dir noch irgendwie weiterhelfen?
Ja, zwar eben, sante der vorige Anrufer irgendwas, wegen dass keine Konsequenzen aus den Sachen folgen, wurden politisch gesehen. Ich lese jetzt hier gerade, da ist eine grüne Innexpertin, Düker heißt die, die nannte das Urteil die höchstrichtliche Bestätigung für den Verrat von Grundrechten durch den FDP Innenminister Wolfgang Wolf. Zudem eine fachliche und handwerkliche Inkompetenz. Da bliebe eben nur noch eine Konsequenz, der Rücktritt. Das ist ja nur schon mal der Ansatz, dass da politisch auch was passieren könnte, wenn die ständig mitkommen. Irgendwann muss es immer eine für die Nuss geben.
Da wird halt ein Internet-Ausdrucker durch einen anderen Internet-Ausdrucker ersetzt.
Der Punkt ist, wenn alle Minister, die so ein Gerichtsurteil zu verantworten haben, also die das Gesetz geschrieben haben, jedes Mal zurücktreten müssen, dann hätten wir echt ein Karussell an Rücktritten. Weil es sind ja nur wirklich schon eine ganze Latte angesetzt.
Man sollte vielleicht in dem Zusammenhang nicht vergessen, dass auch gerade Landtagswahlen quer durch die Bundesrepublik ziehen und dass da auch so ein bisschen parteipolitisches Karten-Gemische dazugehört.
Das liegt einfach daran, dass das ein bisschen ja, geplänkelt ist von den Wahlen.
Ich weiß nicht, also das ist... Kann man durchaus als Nuance mit einfließen lassen.
Also Verrat von Grundrechten, das ist schon heftig.
Man muss das wohl so nennen. Also ich meine, die Richter waren ja da sehr deutlich. Das ist halt nichtig und zwar aus mehr als einem Grund. Also sie haben die Verfassung hier schon missachtet.
Genau, und das ist also für einen Innenminister, der die Verfassung eigentlich achten soll, zwar die NRW-Verfassung, aber ist das eigentlich ein Rücktrittsgrund. Sehe ich es wirklich so.
Wir hätten nichts dagegen.
Und dann wünsche ich euch noch einen schönen Abend.
Wir sollten jetzt mal ganz kurz eine Musik spielen, auch mit besonderen Grüßen an den Rest vom CTC, nämlich an Tim, der ein Stück Musik ausgesucht hat, was in dieser Sendung heute laufen soll. Es kommt von Die Computers. Ich bin gespannt.
Ich bin ja aber......schlecht drauf.
Das ist ja gleich zu Ende. Wenn es ein Essen wäre, könnte man sagen, gut, das muss man auch mal gekostet haben.
An dieser Stelle danke an Tim.
Danke an Tim, aber wir wollen bei der Gelegenheit vielleicht noch auf den Chaosradio Express hinweisen, denn in der nächsten Zeit gab es wirklich tolle Sendungen, insbesondere die zu Hubschraubern und die zu World of Warcraft. Also wer Lust hat, kann sich die als Podcast holen und wir wollen auch darauf verweisen, dass der Chaos Computer Club demnächst mit seiner wirklich sehr bemerkenswerten Zeitschrift da Tinschleude rauskommt.
So viel zum Thema Eigenwerbung. Sie hörten in der Werbesendung Chaosradio 132. Frank, Erdgeist, Konstanze und Jakob sind hier bei Fritz. Ihr könnt anrufen 0331 77 97 110. Wir reden über den heutigen Beschluss vom Bundesverfassungsgericht, die gesagt haben, Online-Durchsuchung, my ass, baby. Im weitesten Sinne. Am Telefon ist Andi.
Hallo Andi. Hallo Welt, ja.
Hallo Welt, war ein super Stück Musik, oder?
Der Wahnsinn.
Der Wahnsinn. Ich glaube, es war eher das Wahnsinn. Aber das ist ja in dem Fall auch egal. Andi, was hast du beizutragen zu unserer Lust und Ohne?
Ich wollte eigentlich nur meine unglaubliche Erleichterung über das heutige Urteil zum Ausdruck bringen. Und ich erhoffe mir eigentlich auch jede Menge Signalwirkung für die ganze restliche Überwachungsscheiße, die gerade so läuft.
Das hatten wir ja vorhin schon kurz erwähnt und zur Kenntnis gegeben, dass auch die Richter heute das Wort Vorratsdatenspeicherung äußerst kritisch formuliert haben.
Du hattest gesagt, du hast mal eine gebrauchte Festplatte gekauft?
Ja, richtig, habe ich mal gemacht.
Was war denn da drauf?
Habe ich nicht weiter geschaut. Also ich hatte mal stapelalte Festplatten gekauft, wo teilweise noch Herstellergarantie drauf war und die waren eigentlich als defekt deklariert. Und als ich die nacheinander bei mir angestöpselt habe, habe ich gemerkt, dass auf der einen noch ein Dateisystem drauf war. Die war halt nicht mal formatiert und habe halt da irgendwie eine Verzeichnisstruktur gesehen, habe da gar nicht weiter, habe dann aber nicht weiter durchsucht oder so, dann habe die dann gleich mit hier binären Zufallszahlen überschrieben, bevor ich sie dann zum Hersteller geschickt habe.
Nicht ein kleines Fitzelchen Neugier in dir?
Nee, das hat mich auch überhaupt nicht interessiert, weil ich ehrlich gesagt ja schon perplex war, dass da jemand irgendwie bei einem Computerlager, wo ich das gekauft habe, seine Festplatte irgendwie abgibt, ohne die vorher so formatiert wenigstens zu vertieren.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie die EC-Karte liegen lassen, die Nummer drauf schreiben.
Zum Thema Festplatten, da gibt es ja gerade diesen massiven Skandal in Hongkong, in China, Entschuldigung. Wo ein großer Schauspieler, also der sehr bekannteste Lokal, hat halt seinen Computer zum Reparieren gegeben. Und da waren halt noch lauter Bilder von seinen weiblichen Eroberungen drauf. Und die halt dann von dem Techniker da geborgen und irgendwie in die Inhalt gepumpt wurden, was jetzt halt zu einem unglaublichen Skandal führt. Zum Beispiel, dass eine dieser Schauspielerinnen, die da irgendwie beteiligt war, halt jetzt nicht mehr die Öffnung von der Olympiade machen darf, weil sie halt in diesen Skandal verwickelt sind und so weiter, also in China wird gerade auch in großem Umfang Sensibilisierung für private Daten auf privaten Computern betrieben. Das ist halt ein Klassiker. Also es findet immer wieder statt, dass Leute halt ihre Daten nicht schützen, wenn sie ihre Computer zur Reparatur geben. Und naja, man kann sich überlegen, was da für Leute arbeiten heutzutage so bei Computer-Reparatur betrieben. Die sind dann halt im Zweifel auch neugierig.
Ja, da kommt eigentlich noch eine andere Problematik dazu, denn es ist tatsächlich auch so, dass in Deutschland die Ermittlungsbehörden immer mehr auszuwertende Festplatten an Privatfirmen weitergeben. Das heißt, dass man sich nicht mehr unbedingt darauf verlassen kann, wenn man schon beschlagnahmte Festplatte irgendwie abgeben muss, dass der Staat die auswertet, sondern die werden einfach an dritte Dienstleister gegeben. Auch hier ist natürlich nach dem heutigen Urteil doch hoffentlich eine Änderung dieser Praxis zu erwarten.
Ja, also die Landeskriminalämter saufen halt den Festplatten, weil halt bei jeder Hausbesuchung werden halt computer mitgenommen. Also praktisch jeder.
Ich lasse meine alten Festplatten auch immer gleich mitnehmen von den Beamten.
Ich habe vielleicht da noch eine Frage zu den Festplatten bei den Ermittlungsbehörden. Und zwar sind ja irgendwie alle meine Festplatten habe ich AES verschlüsselt mit lang langen Passwörtern. Und es würde mich interessieren, was die Ermittlungsbehörden da machen können, um die trotzdem zu knacken.
Sie gucken sich natürlich an, was noch außerhalb des Kryptosystems ist und typischerweise gucken sie halt danach, was halt an Passwortresten möglicherweise noch im Swap-File ist und so weiter. Auch da haben heute die Verfassungsrichter ein sehr interessantes Statement zu abgegeben. Sie haben nämlich gesagt, dass die Verschlüsselung von Daten tatsächlich ein informationeller Selbstschutz ist, der ein Recht ist. Das heißt also, das kann tatsächlich, also das Ab- Umgehen dieses informationellen Selbstschutzes stellt wiederum einen schweren Grundrechtseingriff dar. Also sprich, wenn sie dir einen Trojaner installieren, um an deine verschlüsselten Daten zu kommen, ist es nochmal tatsächlich ein wesentlich schwerer Grundrechtseingriff, als wenn sie dir nur deine Festplatte beschlagnahmen würden, weil du versuchst, dir aktiv Dinge zu verbargen. Und sie haben halt definiert, dass es dein Recht ist, weil du tatsächlich in dieser Welt heutzutage davon ausgehen musst, dass deine Platte irgendwann mal verloren geht, dein Laptop geklaut wird oder so. Und dass du halt entsprechende Vorkehrungen triffst und du auch davon ausgehen können musst, dass dir auch Gegengangsbehörden helfen.
Was im Zusammenhang mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, die wir vorhin ja schon mal angesprochen haben, wie ich finde, ein weiterer, höchst interessanter Punkt ist, in diesem ganzen großen, großen Urteil, dass Karlsruhe sagt, die Verschlüsselung von Daten und damit die Wahrung meiner eigenen Privatsphäre ist mein Recht. Und nicht wie es früher war, wenn ich meine Daten verschlüsselte oder aber mich darum kümmere, dass keine anderen Leute an meine Daten rankommen, mache ich mich möglicherweise verdächtig, weil ich hätte ja vielleicht etwas zu verbergen. Das finde ich ist ein ganz interessanter Dreh an der ganzen Geschichte. Das erklärt vielleicht auch die Dimension dieses Urteils, was heute passiert ist.
Genau dieser Punkt, dass Verschlüsselung nicht mehr verdächtig ist, ist auch tatsächlich einer der großen Pluspunkte dieses Urteils.
Damit sind wir jetzt einfach auch in eine neue Zeit übergegangen, mit diesem Grundrecht. Denn bei all der Wirtschaftskriminalität und den vielen Spionage-Software-Tools, wenn auch sehr einfacher, die man so aus dem Netz sich einfallen kann, mit seinem normalen Windows-Betriebssystem, müssen wir einfach davon ausgehen, dass das jeder tut. Früher oder später wird das Standard sein und das kann nicht bestraft werden, dadurch, dass man als konspirativ betrachtet wird, nur weil man seine Platten oder Mehls verschlüsselt.
Wir schalten mal gleich weiter. Wir schalten mal zu Thomas, der nämlich eine Frage hat zu, ich glaube, zu Beschlagnahm Festplatten. Andi, hoffe, wir haben deins erstmal erklärt.
Ganz toll, ich wünsche euch einen schönen Abend.
Hallo, nach Saarbrücken. Guten Abend, Thomas. Grüße dich. Wir waren gerade beim Thema Festplatten. Ich glaube, da bist du genau in der Mitte.
Ja, vielleicht, ich weiß nicht. Meine Frage, meine Anerkundung ist eher daher...
Sag mal, telefonierst du aus einer Blechdose?
Nein, nicht direkt.
Na geht so.
Haben wir uns früher auch gebastelt, aus zwei Blechdosen.
Ja, mit einer Strippe in der Mitte. Mach mal weiter, es geht schon.
Mein Ding geht es eher dahin, wie ist denn das mit der Beweiskraft bei der ganzen Sache. Weil bei dem Trojaner, da haben wir schon ein bisschen das Problem, dass da kann er jemand anders manipulieren. Wir hatten es ja gerade eben damit, dass da jemand anderes durch den Trojaner reinkommt. Und das Programm an sich, es arbeitet ja auch heimlich, da kann ja hinterher kein Mensch sehen, was passiert da jetzt, was wird da genau geschlagen haben. Es gibt auch so ein bisschen das Problem, man kann ja auch nicht genau jetzt trennen, was ist jetzt privat und was darf nicht gelesen werden und was gehört jetzt mit dazu. Und vielleicht auch noch kurz, das wäre vielleicht auch noch ein Punkt, wo man vielleicht noch ansetzen könnte. Viele jetzt meinen, okay, der Schweizer, der bastelt sich jetzt da noch irgendwelche Gefahrenlagen und dann setzt man den Trojaner ein, dass man vielleicht da ansetzt und sagt, okay, wir setzen vielleicht so eine hohe Hürde für Beweiskraft da ein, für so Sachen, die jetzt aus dem Bundestrojaner da ausspringen, dass es hinterher im Prinzip eigentlich nutzlos ist, weil es überhaupt nicht mehr einsetzbar ist.
Also was wir halt unterscheiden müssen ist, die reden da momentan nicht von Ansatz des Trojaners zur Beweissicherung im Strafverfahren, sondern zur Gefahrenabwehr. Das heißt also, was da immer wieder betont wird und darum ging das Urteil heute auch, ist tatsächlich präventives Handeln. Also sprich, irgendjemand wird verdächtigt irgendwie Terrorist zu sein, begründet in diesem Fall und so weiter und so fort mit hohen Schranken. Und man will gucken, dass man diesen Anschlag, den der plant, verhindert bekommt. So das ist halt so die Argumentation, die die bringen. Dann werden sie es einsetzen. Zum Thema Beweiskraft habe ich bisher in der Urteilsbegründung tatsächlich nichts gefunden. Also das ist tatsächlich weiterhin offen. Keine Ahnung, also bleibt tatsächlich abzuwarten, was da passiert.
Für den präventiven Bereich ist das schlicht nicht relevant.
Das ist irrelevant, genau. Was jetzt die Beweiskraft von beschlagnahmten Daten auf normalen Festplatten betrifft, ist es so, dass es eigentlich einen Prozess gibt, in dem sichergestellt wird, dass zum Beispiel nicht mit der Festplatte, die aus dem Rechner ausgebaut wurde, gearbeitet wird, sondern auf einer Kopie dieser Platte, die eigentlich die Platte weggeschlossen wird. Und du halt im Zweifel im Strafverfahren das Recht hast vergleichen zu lassen, ob tatsächlich die Kopie identisch ist mit dem, was bei dir beschlagnahmt wurde, usw. Es gibt da eigentlich eine Reihe von Regularien. Es ist aber tatsächlich so, dass die in der Praxis extrem schlampig gehandhabt werden. Es gibt immer wieder Fälle, wo Rechtsanwälte finden, dass zum Beispiel die Daten, die dann zurückkommen mit den Festplatten aus der Asservatenkammer, nicht mit denen aus dem Backup übereinstimmen, dass da teilweise Software installiert wird und dergleichen Dinge mehr. Und bis hin dazu, dass tatsächlich diese Festplattenauswertung von Privatfirmen vorgenommen wird, also gerade in den Fällen von Ohrheberrechtsverletzungen, wo dann auch sehr fragwürdig ist, wie qualifiziert die da arbeiten. Also es gibt eigentlich tatsächlich Vorschriften und Prozesse dafür, die sicherstellen sollen, dass halt nur genau diese Daten verwendet werden. Aber in der Realität sieht es häufig in der Praxis sehr anders aus. Also da muss man dann halt tatsächlich, wenn man davon betroffen ist, empfiehlt sich ein Anwalt zu suchen, der das schon mal durch hat und damit Erfahrungen hat. Und hat da auch genau hinzugucken. Also den Beweiserhebungen, die da aus den Strafverfolgungsbehörden kommen, gerade im digitalen Bereich, kann man da nicht bedingungslos trauen.
Geklärt, Thomas?
Jetzt vielleicht noch irgendwie einen Punkt zu dieser Sache, was das Grundrecht uns jetzt noch bringt irgendwie. Was ich noch wichtig fand, ist, dass wir diesen Bereich der Privatsphäre noch sehr viel weiter ausgedehnt hatten. Vorher hatte man irgendwie so das Gefühl, dass Laptops und mobile Geräte, die sind sobald aus dem Haus im Freibild, und auch E-Mails und so, die auf dem IMAP-Server liegen. Und da hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht eigentlich recht deutlich gesagt, dass es eigentlich auch alles irgendwie schutzbedürftig ist.
Ja klar, es geht nicht nur tatsächlich um die Festplatte, sondern sie haben wirklich mehr erwähnt. Etwa eben die Passwörter, die Caches, die Daten. Also man hat eigentlich einen neuen Bereich des virtuellen Lebens, der mitgeschützt ist. Da hast du dann schon Kopf getroffen. Ich denke auch, das wird sicherlich erst in 5 oder 10 Jahren, wenn man überblicken kann, wie wichtig dieses neue Grundrecht für uns ist.
Da wir gerade im juristischen Thema sind, Thomas, hat er ja was zur Beweiskraft von Beschlagnahmen Festplatten. Vielleicht kann Jakob noch etwas dazu beitragen, weil der möchte nämlich gerne noch was wissen zum Richtervorbehalt. Thomas, dir vielen Dank für den Anruf und einen schönen Abend. Tschüss. Namens Jakob.
Hallo.
Mach mal deine Frage so, dass auch ich die verstehe. Weil auf dem Zeichnen im Monitor verstehe ich es gerade nicht.
Ja, ich wollte eigentlich relativ wenig fragen. Ich wollte eigentlich nur ein paar Anmerkungen. Zum Richtervorbehalt war mein Eindruck, als ich das heute gelesen habe, dass es eben nicht nur eine relativ hohe Hürde ist, sondern dass es wirklich eine Weiterentwicklung des Richtervorbehalts ist. Also mehr oder weniger Richtervorbehalt 2.0. Einfach weil der Richter ja wirklich begründen muss, was wir ja vorhin auch schon gehört haben.
Dass es nicht nur in Formularen abzustempeln geht. Genau.
Und ich denke, das ist sehr wichtig, weil ich glaube, es gibt eine wissenschaftliche Untersuchung zur Telekonditionsüberwachung, wo einfach ganz klar zu sehen war, dass dieser Richtervorbehalt in dieser Form, wie er bisher gehandhabt wurde, überhaupt nichts gebracht hat.
Das war Max-Planck-Institut für Strafrecht, wer das nachlesen möchte.
Ja, genau.
Das ist natürlich richtig. Aber ich habe dir den Gedanken selber auch erhabt, als ich in K2 saß und von der eingehenden Prüfung durch den Richter gesprochen wurde. Aber man muss wohl sagen, dass man hier nicht jeden Richtervorbehalt mit einem anderen vergleichen kann. Und er hängt auch sehr davon ab, was für eine Art von schwerwiegendem Eingriff wir haben. Man darf wahrscheinlich nicht vergleichen eine Hausdurchsuchung, die ja auch von einem Richter entschieden wird, und eben sowas wie einen großen Lauschangriff oder die Online-Durchsuchung. Ich denke, dass es das heute schon gibt, diese richterliche Prüfung mit eingehender Begründung. Ich glaube, das ist nicht so neu. Aber nun sind wir auch keine Juristen. Das ist sicherlich eine Frage, die ja auch im juristischen Schriftdruck jetzt debattiert wird. Man muss sich überlegen, was nach so einem Urteil kommt. Dann streiten die sich da monatelang in den Zeitschriften. Auf jeden Fall ist es sicherlich eine Menge interessante Sachen zu lesen. Aber meiner Meinung nach ist das nicht wirklich neu.
Ja, ich hab auch allgemein noch was zu dem BKA-Gesetz zu sagen eigentlich.
Was er demnächst erst ansteht.
Ja, genau. Das wird jetzt vermutlich ziemlich rasch kommen. Also ich hab das damals, als es ja vom CCC veröffentlicht wurde, mit sehr viel Freude gelesen. Weil ich hab da grad ein Praktikum beim Sächsischen Datenschutzbeauftragten gemacht.
Echt?
Jaja, also Freude, dass ich das für meine Arbeit zur Verfügung gestellt gekriegt hab. Herzlichen Dank nochmal.
Bitte, bitte.
Und wir haben natürlich hier jetzt natürlich hohe Hürden für die Online-Durchsuchung. Ich denke, was wir nicht vergessen dürfen, ist, wir haben diesen Eingriff jetzt. Und dieses BKA-Gesetz baut ja unser BKA immerhin zu einem halben Geheimdienst um, wenn nicht zu einem ganzen. Und ich denke, das sollten wir in der ganzen Geschichte nicht vergessen.
Ja, klar, wir haben auch versucht, das immer zu betonen, dass diese Online-Durchsuchung im gesamten BKA-Gesetzentwurf nur ein kleines Steinchen ist im Puzzle. Das ist wohl ein ganz wichtiger Hinweis.
So, diese Geschichte dieser Artikel 20 des BKA-Gesetzes geht von A bis Y. Und das war schon echt heftig, als wir es damals gehört haben.
Kannst du den vielleicht ganz kurz erläutern? Artikel 20, was steht da drin?
Artikel 20 regelt die Befugnisse, die das BKA künftig zusätzlich zu den bisherigen Befugnissen haben wird. Bisher ist das BKA eigentlich eine mehr oder weniger koordinierende Behörde, so was zumindest ursprünglich mal gedacht ist, um die Landeskriminalämter irgendwie zu koordinieren. Und mit diesen Befugnissen in Paragraf 20, eben wie gesagt, 20a bis y, die komplette Palette, gibt es von der Online-Durchsuchung über Telekommunikationsüberwachung, Arbeit mit Imseacatcher, also...
Der Spähangriff, der Zugriff auf private Datensammlungen, da ist echt alles drin.
Da ist das volle Programm drin. Und damit wird aus einer mehr oder weniger koordinierenden Polizeibehörde eine Polizeibehörde, die auch in Wohnungen einbrechen darf, die auch Personen kontrollieren darf. Also wirklich eine Polizeibehörde, die auch wirklich geheimdienstliche Befugnisse letztlich hat. Und das ist was, was wir eigentlich seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg nicht mehr haben wollten.
Richtig, ja, das ist absolut korrekt. Und man kann es sogar noch drastischer sagen. Wir hatten früher eine Polizei, die hat Verbrecher verfolgt. Heute ist es so, dass es versucht wird, diese BKA so aufzustellen, dass im Prinzip die ganzen Vorfeldermittlungen macht. Also Leute, wo sie eventuell vermuten, die könnten ja mal, und die eigentliche Aufgabe des BKA nämlich Verbrecher zu fangen, tritt da vielmehr in den Hintergrund so weit, dass sie die Geheimdienste in Deutschland schon aufregen, dass ihnen quasi der Aufgabenbereich weggeschnappt wird.
Gut, aber ich glaube, das ist auch ein Thema für eine der nächsten Sendungen, was jetzt an dieser Stelle nicht ausführlich diskutieren lässt. Da werden wir demnächst noch viel Spaß haben.
Einen letzten Punkt, sowas, was vorhin angesprochen wurde, das war der Punkt, ich hab doch nichts zu befürchten und ich hab doch nichts zu verbergen. Das ist immer mein Lieblingsthema. Ich glaub, Frank hat da mal was ganz Gutes zugesagt, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es Frank war, aber ich unterstelle es ihm jetzt mal. Das war die Geschichte. Man hat das gar nicht mehr zu entscheiden. Wenn man sich beispielsweise die 129-Jahre-Verfahren, also die Terrorismusverfahren des letzten Jahres, anschaut, dann sieht man einfach, dass eine bestimmte Menge an Informationen genommen, kategorisiert und interpretiert wird. Und zwar in einer Art und Weise, auf die man als Einziger überhaupt keinen Einfluss mehr hat. Und dann stellt sich die Frage nicht mehr, ob man was zu verbergen hat oder nicht, sondern einfach, ob das eigene Verhalten in einer gewissen Art und Weise interpretierbar ist.
Und wie das Verfassungsgericht heute ja festgestellt hat, ist das Verschlüsseln von Daten Recht, was man privat ausüben darf und nicht mehr ein Verdachtsmoment. Jakob, wir müssen Nachrichten machen, weil ansonsten drehen die uns ihren Hals um. Schönen Abend noch! Und im Chaosradio geht's gleich weiter unter der 0331 70 97 110. Unter anderem mit der Frage von Tobias aus dem Schwarzwald. Werden eigentlich auch Politiker überwacht?
Fritz 15.
Das Fritz-Geburtsdags-Festival am kommenden Samstag in der Arena Berlin Treto ist jetzt leider total ausverkauft. Wer schon Karten hat, hat Glück. Wer noch keine hat, braucht viel Glück. Denn die allerletzten Karten für Fritz 15 gibt's nur noch zu gewinnen. Einfach gut Fritz hören. Das FETZ-Geburtstags-Festival der Arena Berlin Treto. Jetzt also total ausverkauft. für alle, die nicht dabei sein können, wollen oder dürfen, übertragen wir's live im Radio. Mehr Infos fritz.de Kommen am Samstag so ungefähr ab 18 Uhr und dann die ganze lange Nacht auf Fritz. Fritz 15.
Nachrichten mit Philipp Bürger.
Die Bundesregierung hat das Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts zu heimlichen Online-Durchsuchungen begrüßt. Die Richter hätten deutlich gemacht, dass der Staat im Kampf gegen terroristische Bedrohungen nicht darauf verzichten könne, sagte ein Regierungssprecher. Gleichzeitig seien die Grundrechte der Bürger gestärkt worden. Denn die Sicherheitsbehörden dürfen die Computer- und Onlineprofile von Verdächtigen nur dann ausspionieren, wenn Menschenleben oder der Bestand des Staates in großer Gefahr sind. Die Durchsuchung muss von einem Richter angeordnet werden. Die Berliner Polizei hat am Nachmittag einen Club der Rockergruppe Bandidos in Reinickendorf durchsucht. 200 Beamte waren im Einsatz. Ein 23-jähriger Mann wurde laut Polizei festgenommen. Er soll an einem Überfall auf zwei Männer vor einem Vereinshaus der Hells Angels in Charlottenburg beteiligt gewesen sein. Die Täter hätten die Mitglieder des verfeindeten Motorradclubs zum Teil schwer verletzt. In Bremen haben Polizisten bei Ermittlungen ihrer Informanten offenbar mit Drogen geschmiert. Die Staatsanwaltschaft hat sechs verdächtige Beamte auf der Liste. Sie sollen in mehreren Fällen Marihuana und Haschisch zur Belohnung verteilt haben. Ihre Diensträume und Wohnungen wurden durchsucht und Rauschgift sichergestellt. Gebäudereiniger bekommen ab 1. März einen gesetzlichen Mindestlohn. Das teilte das Bundeswetsministerium mit. Man habe sich in der Regierung darauf geeinigt, dass der Mindestlohn wie von den Tarifparteien vereinbart gezahlt werde. Danach beträgt das Mindestgehalt im Westen 8, 15 Euro und im Osten 6, 58 Euro. Im Viertelfinale des DFB-Pokals haben sich Wolfsburg und Hamburg gegenüber gestanden. Gewonnen hat Gastgeber Wolfsburg mit 2 zu 1 nach Verlängerung und steht damit im Halbfinale. Auch das zweite Spiel des Abends wurde nach Verlängerung entschieden. Bayern München besiegte im Lokalderby den ewigen Konkurrenten 1860 München mit 1 zu 0. In der deutschen Eishockeyliga haben die Hannover Scorpions 4 zu 3 nach Verlängerung gegen die Frankfurt Lions gewonnen. Die aktuellen Temperaturen Neuropin und Wittenberge 4 Grad, Potsdam Frankfurt und Angermünde 5 Grad, Cottbus und Berlin 6 Grad. Es ist stark bewölkt draußen, es gibt Regenschauer, es wird recht stürmisch, oder ist es schon? In der Nacht bleibt es dann aber trocken, das Ganze bei Temperaturen zwischen 4 und 1 Grad. Morgen erwarten uns wieder viele Wolken, die sich ab und zu aber auch verziehen. Es soll trocken bleiben, morgen 8 bis 11 Grad wird es maximal. A24 Pritzwald Richtung Berlin Zwischen den Ausfahrten Fährberlin und Kremen liegen Hindernisse und Gegenstände auf der Fahrbahn. Die rechte Spur ist blockiert. Fahrt bitte vorsichtig. Es ist noch nicht bekannt, um was für Gegenstände es sich da handelt. A13 Schönefelder Kreuz Richtung Dresden Zwischen Mittenwalde und Groß-Köris gab es einen Unfall. Bitte fahrt langsam.
Bundestrojaner können sie nicht sein. Die sind nicht so groß.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 101, 5, dann Fritz in Eisenhüttenstadt.
Ich hab es schon mal gesehen. Ich hab es schon mal gesehen. Ich hab es schon mal gesehen. Ich hab es schon mal gesehen. Ich hab es schon mal gesehen.
Ich hab es schon mal gesehen.
Ich hab es schon mal gesehen. Ich hab es schon mal gesehen. Ich hab es schon mal gesehen. Ich hab es schon mal gesehen. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz, wir haben noch knapp 20 Minuten. Wer sich jetzt ins Fadenkreuz genommen, kommen jetzt irgendwelche Behörden daher, von denen ich vielleicht noch nie irgendwas gehört habe, und die fangen jetzt an, in meinem Privatleben rumzuschnüffeln, um am Ende möglicherweise dann etwas herauszuholen, was mich dann schädigen könnte in meiner politischen Laufbahn, oder mich diskreditieren könnte mit meiner Meinung. Und darum geht es ja, da geht es ja nicht nur darum, machen die das auch, sondern nur, könnten sie es tun? Also ich will der Regierung das nicht unterstellen, aber was in den Klappfingern so vorgeht, ist ja das, was eigentlich interessiert in diesem Zeitpunkt. Und das fördert halt eben, das führt dazu, dass dann Leute nicht mehr so aktiv, in der politischen Opposition aktiv werden, wie sie das eigentlich sollten in unserer Demokratie oder wie sie das könnten.
Also ich denke mal, das Beispiel des G8-Gipfels hat sehr deutlich gezeigt, dass es tatsächlich stattfindet. Also dass politische Opposition in Deutschland mit polizeilichen Mitteln unterbunden wird und bestraft wird. Und das ist halt nur eines von vielen Beispielen. Also gerade in den südlichen Bundesländern ist es ja durchaus auch noch durchaus üblich, dass mit polizeilichen Mitteln gegen lokale Aktivisten vorgegangen wird, also Umweltaktivisten zum Beispiel. Oder Leute, die halt zum Beispiel gegen lokale Großprojekte agieren. Das ist halt überhaupt nicht selten, das passiert durchaus täglich so. Also kann man nicht als theoretisch abtun, sondern das ist tatsächlich ein Fakt, ja.
Also man muss vielleicht da auch immer noch mal bedenken, die Technik, die technische Infrastruktur, die gebaut wird, die ist erst mal da. Die Regeln, die diese beschränkt, sind durch Gesetze geregelt. Und die kann man einfach ändern. Wenn man aber jetzt die Technik so hinbaut, dann muss man sich auch überlegen, wer kann vielleicht später diese Regeln machen und ändern. Insofern, man muss auch mal ein bisschen in die Zukunft gucken, wenn man sich solche Überwachungstechniken ansieht, ja.
Genau. Und eben in dem Moment, wo man solche Techniken schafft, oder auch nur darüber überlegt und sie teilweise einsetzt, hat man bereits verloren.
Genau, dann eigentlich ist unser Staat, so wie es die Richter gesagt haben, eigentlich dafür da, gerade in dieser digitalen Welt uns zu schützen, vor allem anderen fiesen Menschen, die so im Netz rumschwirren und unsere, weiß ich nicht, Fische, unsere Passwörter irgendwie auch spionieren wollen und nicht sich selber als dieser Datensammler zu gerieren. Das halten, naja, wahrscheinlich brauchen wir noch eine Weile, bis die Politiker mal erkennen, was den CCC betrifft. So haben wir ja schon seit vielen Jahren gefordert, dass es so eine Art von digitaler Intimsphäre geben soll. Und wir hoffen doch sehr, dass nicht jetzt auch noch die Politiker so lange brauchen, um zu begreifen, dass wir das jetzt haben, dieses Grundrecht.
Stillschweigend werden hier Flüssigkeiten zusammengekriegt.
Stilles Wasser.
Stilles Wasser, deswegen sagst du nicht so viel. Tobias, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Okay, ich sage noch, die Kapitel in München ist toll.
So, und der nächste ist Fortnull, nee, wie heißt du?
FTnull, hallo.
FTnull, Narbent.
Genau, ich komme aus NRW und erstmal herzlichen Dank an euch Berliner. Ihr habt da echt gute Arbeit geleistet und den Karren hier aus dem Dreck gezogen.
Ja, wenn ihr das nicht auf die Reihe kriegt, wa?
Ja, das ist irgendwie so eine Sache.
Die Pressearbeit in Berlin ist echt viel besser. Was ich eigentlich nur ganz kurz anmerken wollte, weil bestimmt noch ganz viele andere Leute da fragen wollen, mir sind zwei Absätze aufgefallen und zwar zum einen irgendwie Absatz 223. Da ist was zur Beweiskraft von so abgeschnäuchelten Daten gesagt. Ich glaube aber, das ist irgendwie als Antwort auf eine der Einsprüche gedacht.
Na, es geht ja immer nur um die Kläger und was sie eigentlich vorgebracht haben. Aber du hast da schon den richtigen Abschnitt erwischt.
Da ist halt kurz gesagt, dass die erhobenen Daten, die man mit so einem Bundestrojaner hat abgeschnäuchelt hat, dass die eigentlich keinen Beweis wert haben, weil man keine exklusive Kontrolle über den Rechner hatte. Das fand ich interessant.
Na ja, sag aber die ganze Wahrheit. Was steht da nämlich eigentlich? Nämlich, dass das keine Rolle spielt, da die an Verfassungsschutzbehörden geht.
Genau.
Und die haben manchmal die Informationinteresse, ohne dass man überhaupt die vor Gerichtsfest haben muss.
Genau, es geht ja dann um die Information und nicht da, dass das irgendwie als Gerichtsfestbeweise ist. Das andere, was mir aufgefallen ist, ist Absatz 183. Das ist doch eigentlich die absolute Ohrfeige gegen die Vorratsdags-Speicherung, wenn ich das richtig gelesen hab.
Genau, also 183, 184.
Genau, das haben wir genau so interpretiert.
Okay, super, dann sehe ich das richtig. Das wollte ich eigentlich auch nur sagen. Und das mit den Beweisen, das war nur, weil Frank vorhin sagte, dass er dazu beweisen eigentlich nichts in der Urteilgründung gefunden hat und nicht einfach mal nach Beweisen gedacht hat.
Ja, es ist nicht so, dass sie völlig nachlesen wollen. Aber es gibt auch www.bundesverfassungsgericht.de gibt es die Urteil- und die Begründung auch für alle zum Klicken, sodass er wüsste, über welche Artikel wir hier reden.
Danke, Herr Geiss.
Es ist so, dass sie dann live, also der Gerichtspräsident Papier, nicht das komplette Urteil verliest, sondern Teile weglässt und in der mündlichen Urteilsbegründung taucht es so nicht auf.
Ist das beabsichtigt? Ist das Zufall?
Ja, das würde einfach zu lange dauern. Es ist ja so schon etwa anderthalb Stunden, dass also da verlesen wird.
Nee, aber dass da bestimmte Passagen nicht verlesen werden.
Nein, er verweist dann auf die schriftliche Begründung.
Genau, also die mündliche Urteilsbegründung ist in der Regel auch noch mal ein bisschen aufgelockert, also zu sagen...
Klar, gestigen Mimik sind ja auch dabei.
Also und er verweist noch mal auf die, sozusagen aus Sicht des Gerichts, wichtigen Punkte in dem Urteil.
Und er guckt in die richtige Richtung.
Genau, also der Papier, das ist halt toll. Der sitzt halt da vorne und schwenkt halt seinen belehrenden Zeigefinger und guckt halt über genau die Leute an, die er meint.
Das ist großartig. Wer hätte gedacht, dass eine Sitzung vom Bundesverfassungsgericht so amüsant sein kann?
Das kam leider bei Phoenix nicht ganz so rüber, weil man ihn immer nur von vorne gesehen hat.
Und bei Phoenix haben sie leider um die Ausnahmen dieses Gesetzes, also um die Ausnahmen dieser Ermächtigungen quasi ging, da haben sie leider genau abgeblendet mit einem völlig uninteressanten Experten befragt.
Das hat man leider nicht mitbekommen.
Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht gibt es später noch mal eine andere Aufzeichnung von. Aber gut, das war es von mir eigentlich schon wieder.
Bitte.
Hannes hat noch einen höchst interessanten Beitrag zur Diskussion. Name Hannes. Du rufst an aus Ilmenau.
Genau, in Thüringen.
In Thüringen. Wie kriegst du da Fritz?
Ja, über das Internet.
Ey, du bist auch einer der wenige, die eine grandiose Telefonleitung haben.
Ja, sogar über OMTS. Man höre einen Staunen.
Wow, also nicht jemand, der mit einer Blechdose telefoniert.
Nee.
Okay, ehe wir jetzt weiterplänkeln, wir haben nicht mehr viel Zeit. Schieß los.
Genau, zum Schluss. Ich wollte noch mal wissen, und zwar, das Problem der Kriminalität hat jetzt ja irgendwie nicht nur Deutschland. Und deswegen würde mich interessieren, wie reagieren jetzt die anderen EU-Länder darauf? Oder haben die vielleicht schon irgendwelche Gesetze diesbezüglich?
Also gibt es in den anderen europäischen Staaten sowas wie die Online-Durchsuchung, Bundesverfassungsgericht, was hier gerade…
Ja, es gibt es tatsächlich. Es gibt einige Europäische, die diese Ermächtigung für ihre Polizeien oder für ihre Geheimdienste haben, aber eine Minderheit. Ich habe es zum Beispiel bei Zypern gelesen. Also die größeren Länder, die einen entscheidenderen Einfluss haben, in Brüssel, die sind bisher alle noch so im Streit. Es gibt aber durchaus in den anderen Ländern auch diesen politischen Streit.
Also insofern setzt Deutschland da schon starker Akzent. Also wenn man vergleicht zum Beispiel mit Großbritannien, wo es den sogenannten RIP Act gibt, wo dich die Polizei zwingen kann, und zwar dadurch, dass sie sich in den Knast stecken, wenn du dein Passwort vergessen hast, für die Festplattenverschlüsselung sind wir hier tatsächlich wieder mal doch deutlich weiter vorne. Also hat Deutschland mit diesem Urteil doch eine Führungsposition eingenommen, und zwar diesmal ausnahmsweise ein positives.
Und da schmort man so lange im Bau, bis einem wieder einfällt, es ist Erdbeersaft 23.
So ist es. Man kann sich halt überlegen, ob die maximale Länge, die man im Bau schmoren kann, im Verhältnis zu der maximalen Länge, die man wegen der Daten auf der Platte im Bau schmoren kann, steht.
Also sie kann ja mal die Länder nennen, wenn es jetzt sehr von Interesse ist. Das wäre schon interessant zu erfahren. Ja, das ist nämlich Zypern, Lettland, Spanien und Rumänien. Da haben wir richtig so eine große Demokratie.
Also nichts, wo man eh hin auswandern wollte.
Spanien?
Ach na ja.
Na ja, wird es sich ja einfach mal interessant zu wissen, wie die das Hand haben. Ich meine, die wollen ja vielleicht auch wissen, was ihre Leute im Internet machen oder auf ihren Rechnern rumfliegen haben, die immer mit ähnlichen Problemen zu kennen, zu kämpfen. Jetzt zum Beispiel auch Spanien oder Großbritannien, die ja nun auch in der Vergangenheit entsprechend mit diesen Anschlägen zu tun hatten.
Das fällt mir ein. Österreich natürlich auch. Die haben ja jüngst diesen Bundestrojaner auch beschlossen. Es ist natürlich klar, dass es internationalen Trend ist. Einer hat die Idee und die Innenminister reden ja auch miteinander. Es wird wohl sehr schwer als Idee einzudämmen sein. Wir werden hier doch in Deutschland Glück haben, dass wir diese Online-Übersuchung mit so hohen Schranken haben. Da können wir uns glücklich schätzen.
Danke Hannes. Das war's. Und am Telefon ist Remo, Name Remo. Du hast ziemlich lange warten müssen. Ich hoffe, da ist auch dein Verständnis, weil hier ist ja Hölle los gerade.
Ja, ist nicht das Problem. Für mich ist eigentlich die Frage, ob man unbedingt die Terroristen damit abfangen kann, die Osama bin Laden, die sich da wahrscheinlich eher über die Nachrichten über irgendwelche Läufer rüber schicken anstatt übers Internet. Ja genau, Brieftauben oder einfach mal... Oder so, weil es ähnlich ist, oder einfach, indem man einfach mal jemanden schickt, der sagt, hier, zu dir muss die Nachricht und dann bringen die ihm das hin.
Also wenn ich dich richtig verstehe, zielt es darauf ab, ob dieses ganze System der Online-Überwachung, Bundestrojaner überhaupt dorthin geht, wo es eigentlich hin soll.
Also ich glaube mal eher, dass man eher auf diesen Pelophilenring abgesehen hat, dass man die Leute damit kaschen kann.
Filesharing.
Das ist wahrscheinlich wesentlich höher, als wenn man irgendwo versucht, da irgendwie die Alkei dazu attakieren. Das wird man wohl wahrscheinlich weniger schaffen.
Aber es sind ja zwei Bereiche. Betroffen ist ja unter anderem in diesem Verfassungsschutzgesetz auch die Frage, ob man online etwa Foren durchsuchen kann. Also die eigentliche Online-Durchsuchung. Also nicht die Durchsuchung der Festplatte, sondern des Netzes. Und da ist es durchaus so, dass das erlaubt ist. Das hat auch das Verfassungsschutzgesetz heute nochmal betont. Und wenn du zum Beispiel so einen Pelophilenring ausheben willst, dann solltest du gucken, wie sie sich dort in den Foren austauschen. Das ist weiterhin erlaubt. Es geht ja um die Ausspielen mit der Festplatte.
Um die digitale Privatsphäre, wie es heute von dir geht.
Aber letztendlich, diese Videos, die schicken sich ja Pelophile teilweise auch. Neuerdings ja nur noch übers Internet hin und her. Die schicken das ja nicht mehr mit der Post. Die Kommunikation ja auch.
Die kann abgehört werden, natürlich.
Das hätte man auch schon vorher machen können. Das hätte man früher auch schon geschafft mit den entsprechenden Gesetzen. Die Sache ist die, ich glaube, man schiebt hier den Terrorismus vor, um andere Sachen wesentlich einfacher machen zu können.
Also davon sind wir ausgegangen bei der Beurteilung der Initialgesetzentwürfe, dass halt der Terrorismus da wieder mal nur die Begründung ist. Dem hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht nun halt ein Riegel vorgeschoben. Sie haben halt gesagt, dass es tatsächlich um Leib und Leben beziehungsweise über Leben des Staates gehen muss. Und deswegen ist sozusagen die Diskussion an der Stelle halt beendet.
Gut, aber die andere Frage ist, wie das dann entsprechend in der Praxis umgesetzt wird.
Das werden wir dann sehen, ja.
Das ist ziemlich, naja, hoffen wir mal, dass dieses Gesetz sinnvoll angewendet wird. Aber viele Sachen werden ja leider nicht sinnvoll angewendet.
Und das Schlusswort für heute, ich weiß, wir warten ganz viele Leute in der Leitung, wir schaffen es einfach, stichtend ergreifend nicht mehr. Schlusswort für heute kriegt Axel, Name, Axel.
Hallo, Name Konstanze, Name den Rest. Namen habe ich eh alle, war ich wieder vergessen.
Wir hatten vorhin das Thema Festplatten, die zu untersuchen sind. Und da das Amt selber nicht schafft, gehen die zu externen Firmen. Da kannst du sicherlich auch ein Lied davon singen.
Ich habe aber noch ein viel größeres Problem. Es ist wunderschön, dass wir jetzt richtig große Hürden intern aufgebaut haben, die verhindern sollen. Dass irgendjemand etwas tut auf dem privaten Rechner, was er nicht. Damit ist aber sozusagen die allgemeine Hürde Relativheit angehoben. Und es kommen andere Ideen meiner Ansicht nach in Betracht, über die man vorher wahrscheinlich gar nicht nachgedacht hat. Wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel auf die Idee käme, also ganz bitterböse gesagt als Staat, ich beschäftige gar nicht mehr den Bundesnachrichtendienst damit, sondern ich suche mir eine ausländische Firma, die richtig gut ist, die im internationalen Sicherheitsbereich wirklich auf Draht ist, die das auch können. Dann gilt für die das deutsche Gesetz sowieso nicht. Wir machen das im Rahmen eines Vertrages, der in einer Größe ist, der in Deutschland nicht nachgefragt werden muss, also mit vielen kleinen Verträgen. Und lassen den dann das einfach tun, an bestimmten Stellen.
Kritiker behaupten, das passiert bereits. Es ist tatsächlich so, dass dieses Überbandespielen im geheimdienstlichen Bereich total üblich ist. Also dass sich die Geheimdienste jeweils aushelfen, wenn sie im nationalen Gesetzesbereich nicht mehr weiterkommen.
Das sind keine Geheimdienste mehr, sondern es geht darum, dass sich private Leute, private Firmen, und die stehen völlig außerhalb jeden Gesetzes.
Also ich meine, es ist so, dass irgendwie, zum Beispiel bei der CIA, es ist bekannt, dass die mittlerweile komplette Operationen von privaten Dienstlästern durchführen lassen. Und da halt dann natürlich sehr viel wenig wird.
Für die gibt es dann gar nichts mehr. Die dürfen dann im Endeffekt alles. Und deshalb habe ich das Gefühl, wir haben zwar jetzt die Schmerzschwelle sehr hoch gesetzt, aber da wir eventuell die Reitschwelle genau so was zu machen, ist dann eher erreicht. Natürlich ist es, wenn das herauskommt, ein riesen Skandal. Aber dann verkeiligt irgendwo die Mittel.
Da sind wir dann halt irgendwie im Bereich der Überwachung der Geheimdienste, was halt ein abendführendes Thema ist.
Ja, das ist ja nochmal ein wirklich großes Problem, weil die Kontrollgremien, die wir haben in Deutschland, also zum Beispiel die parlamentarische Kontrollgremium, sagen viele Mitglieder davon, dass sie ohne nichts zu kontrollieren haben, ist es aber nochmal ein ganz anderes Feld. Es ist schon klar, dass du natürlich mit deinem Denken da sicherlich in die richtige Richtung denkst. Und die jüngsten Veröffentlichungen, die es so gibt an Büchern darüber, egal ob bei uns oder in den USA, deuten auch in die Richtung. Aber das ist halt nochmal ein anderes Feld.
Aber trotz alledem ist der, und deswegen freut mich auch, dass Axel hier das Schlusswort hat, ist dieser Einwand am Ende vom heutigen Chaosradio natürlich absolut berechtigt. Ehe wir jetzt alle uns freudig um die Arme fallen und sagen, hey super, hat doch funktioniert, sollte man vielleicht nicht die wirkliche Realität aus den Augen lassen.
Es gibt noch viel zu tun.
Ja, weil wir müssen dieses Grundrecht auch anwenden, und zwar wir alle. Wenn wir es nicht benutzen und tatsächlich auch mal unsere Festplatten verschlüsseln, unsere E-Mails verschlüsseln, dann wird es ins Leere laufen. Wir müssen als gerade die jüngere Generation auch dahinter stehen. Die Richter haben uns halt geschenkt und wir müssen Geschenk aber auch annehmen.
Nicht nur verschlüsseln, sondern einfach auch mit den eigenen Daten viel bewusster umgehen und schauen, dass man es halt nicht in StudiVZ, genau die Daten, die man sonst auf seiner Festplatte geschützt haben möchte, noch mal ein Klartext hinschreibt.
Ja, schön.
Axel, vielen Dank, gute Besserung, du klingst erkältet.
Ja, reden wir nicht drüber.
Schönen Abend. Das war eine hervorragende Sendung Chaosradio 132. So viele Anrufer hatten wir lange nicht, mir klingeln die Ohren. Und wenn wir jetzt, wir könnten locker noch weitermachen, dann müsste Maxwell Smart aber hier ausflippen, weil wir ihm sonst seinen Night-Flight-Klauen, der in wenigen Minuten beginnt, mit handausgegrabenen Beats und von Mutti zusammengestrickten Breaks und was auch sonst er immer an seiner Kiste dabei hat. Chaosradio.ccc.de ist die Website, auf der ihr nachgucken könnt, was in dieser Sendung und beim CCC passiert unter anderem. Da könnt ihr gucken, wo die Podcasts zu finden sind, könnt euch Chaosradio Express ziehen und alle sonstige Dinge machen. Das war Chaosradio für heute. Wir sagen vielen Dank, verabschieden uns und hören uns spätestens am letzten Mittwoch im März wieder. Das waren Constanze, Frank, Erdgeist und Jakob.